euh partie enfin presque parti nous
allons partir pour pour 4h de folie 4h
de match peut-être même un peu plus hein
si on a si on a de la chance peut-être
que le suspense sera là jusqu'au bout
contrairement à hier le match a été très
vite plié un côté côté mvl je pense
qu'après 20 minutes de jeu on était déjà
au courant du vainqueur mais les quarts
de niveau entre Google H&M VL est
vraiment pareil il est il est énorme
donc c'est normal que que le match était
puis aussi vite par par le champion
français qui était particulièrement
inspiré hier mais aujourd'hui il y a les
affiruja contre West les sauts ça va
être un match à mon avis nettement plus
serré même si j'espère qu'elle iraita
écrase Wesley l'inverse on a du mal à
l'imaginer quand même à moins de bon
voilà euh
mais donc Ali resa légèrement favori
mais ça m'étonnerait qui qui réussissent
à écraser son son adversaire aujourd'hui
donc
donc attendez je vais juste récupérer le
chat j'allais dire donc on va se
délecter j'espère
pendant au moins au moins trois heures
de suspense je mise là dessus pour moi
hier le match a duré 20 minutes
réellement et on s'est ennuyé entre
guillemets avec avec Baky pendant trois
heures quarante les 3h40 qui ont suivi
aujourd'hui pour moi on espère au moins
trois heures trois heures et quart de
suspense
plus si affinités après c'est comme ça
le format veut que les matchs puissent
puissent être rallonge et inintéressant
mais on a on a besoin on a besoin d'un
match serré est-ce que West apuration le
turbo d'entrée comme il avait fait comme
un contrat Roanne pour pour mettre un
écart et après avoir juste à le gérer
c'est un petit peu ce qui nous inquiète
après bon allumer le turbo contre Ali
resa c'est moins facile que que contre
que contre les vannes donc on verra si
ça suffit je pense pas que Ali resa est
en mode turbo
mais son mode normal devrait devrait
suffire
sauf quand c'est quand c'est serré il
essaye de gagner après c'est le mode
gestion
on va attendre pour moi le match devait
commencer à 15h on m'a prévenu à midi
que le match était aujourd'hui j'étais
pas au courant je commente un peu au
pied levé à the level pierre comme comme
disent les Anglais ils m'ont un peu
prévenu comme ça après
surprenant quand même le le calendrier
de ce speechasse avec un quart de finale
qui se joue alors que les 8e ne sont pas
à terminer d'ailleurs j'ai laissé 8e de
finale en haut à droite comme vous
pouvez le voir mais aussi parce que en
réalité
bah c'est ouais on en a encore au 8e
quoi enfin genre ça je peux j'y peux
rien quoi
ça j'y peux rien mais c'est un cas c'est
un quart de finale qui nous mènera
peut-être en demi-finale contre Magnus
Carlsen ou pas ou pas ou pas manus
Carlsen qui a réalisé une belle
performance hier contre visite veni vidi
mais pas beaucoup plus côté indien les
Indiens qui se font
voilà j'ai pas je vais pas me permettre
de dire les termes mais qui se font
écraser
qui se font écraser ouais bon voilà on
va s'arrêter là pour le moment pour une
raison qui met inconnue je n'ai pas
accès aux caméras alors ça doit être un
petit bug de leur côté après je dois
dire que
et ben je comprends pas je comprends pas
bon il y a un petit un petit décalage au
niveau caméra je vais je vais écrire si
jamais ça arrive pas après pour moi les
caméras apportent vraiment un plus dans
les événements IRL autant vous allez me
dire ce que vous en pensez mais je
trouve que sur les événements internet
voir les joueurs devant leur webcam ça
apporte quasiment voire rien
et on est aussi très bien comme ça je
sais pas ce que vous vous en pensez mis
à part quelques petits moments
je trouve que c'est quasiment voire
totalement inutile
donc on a déjà Magnus mvl en 2000 c'est
ça alors on a personne en demi encore
mais Maxime lui il est en quart de
finale il va jouer contre visite qui
devrait
déchirer à moins que visite mette que
contre Sarine pardon à moins que Sarine
mette le turbo ou là ça pourrait être un
match plus compliqué mais sinon
visuellement il est largement favori
eikao et Carl Seine dans ce format là
c'est impossible qui se fasse éliminer
avant à mon avis encore qu'il y aura
peut-être un Carlson nepo qui sera sympa
mais bon ça semble impossible et en ce
qui concerne Ali resa bah c'est là
maintenant son quart de finale donc s'il
gagne ce match il sera en demi tout
simplement
donc là qu'est-ce qui se passe sur dame
pro B2 cavalier A4 un gagne la dame
donc il joue cavalier c'est 6
on va jouer cavalier
bah après pour des événements hybrides
par contre la caméra peut apporter un
vrai plus hein par exemple au hasard
genre dans une bac up
quand on voit vraiment les joueurs venir
s'installer
se poser et jouer leur partie
alors on va on va réussir à récupérer
les câbles
ça y est on va enfin réussir à récupérer
les cames je vais tenter de les
récupérer
donc attendez une petite seconde
ça va me prendre trois quatre minutes
malheureusement
mais nous n'avons pas la solution
autre que de le faire actuellement
manuellement
je vais je vais les mettre les deux
on aura plus qu'à ajuster après
et donc on est parti pour quatre heures
de
grands spectacles
j'ai envie de dire on va en avoir pour
notre argent j'ai plus qu'elles sont les
prix mais on va en avoir pour notre
argent aujourd'hui
oui la forme harmonie
comme disent les anglo-saxons
donc je vais pouvoir je vais les
recadrer complètement dans un deuxième
temps
ouais je trouve pas que ça apporte de
ouf moi les caméras dans ce contexte
c'est pas inutile mais je veux pas que
ce soit indispensable quoi alors dans
les tournois IRL ouais bon après c'est
aussi différent mais je trouve que ça
apporte vraiment vraiment plus
donc
ça développe on va voir peut-être H4 G5
les murs vont sûrement partir pour grand
rock
non on va voir on va voir comment ça
évolue
5 puissance c'est la partie du match
entre guillemets la moins importante et
la plus longue
je trouve que le match commence vraiment
à s'intensifier à partir du 3 + 1 ou à
perso donc après après à peu près deux
heures de match c'est là que ça commence
à devenir important et le plus
intéressant
le 5 + 1 c'est plus le moment où les
joueurs se jauge alors parfois on peut
faire la différence mais sur les matchs
intéressants entre guillemets ça
commence vraiment à rentrer dans le vif
en 3 + 1
et ce que je peux le voir là où
évidemment bah oui oh bah ça va être
plus intéressant avec les valves
évidemment désolé de ne pas avoir mis à
la petite jauge qui va nous permettre de
regarder la jauge à fond c'est vraiment
ça que j'avais oublié sur chetcom on
aime bien mettre la joie ça permet de de
bien voir alors que là on voit la jauge
qui ça doit pas être le meilleur coup là
il a fait le tour des 8 la jauge qui
monte un peu on va voir si
si les blancs vont réussir à jouer un
coup qui permet de garder la jauge ah
elle a un tout petit peu baissée mais
c'était peut-être le bon coup quand même
allez on va voir et ce qui trouve le
coup de la jauge ou pas intéressant
non mais c'est vrai que j'ai oublié de
chasse comme il va ils aiment bien que
tout le monde est la jauge ils disent
que c'est mieux pour poursuivre les
parties c'est vrai que c'est ça ajoute
un quelque chose
permet de voir jauger les coups et de
voir si les coups suivent la jauge qui
d'ailleurs n'est pas très forte puisque
c'est stock fish 16 Lite profondeur 20
donc la je veux même pas dire
grand-chose en réalité mais ça permet de
voir elle revient au milieu cavaler A4
c'était peut-être pas le meilleur coup
et oui et oui en quoi à côté de la jauge
alors que ça paraît un coup pas très
bête parce qu'il veut quand même aller
vers B6 mais il y a peut-être du Fou B7
après
il fait dame B6 un coup qui qui fait
partir un peu la jauge dans le noir
alors que le coup est pas mal parce que
sur dame prend V6 qui est franc B6 sous
V7 il a tout reprend des 6 maintenant
donc le coup par effort mais ce n'est
pas le coup de la jauge
on va voir si Wesley réussit à jauger
son adversaire et à trouver le coup
par le coup de la jauge c'est Dame B7 si
le trouve il va peut-être y avoir un
petit un petit contrôle plug
ça a l'air de marcher un B7 de l'ordi
et il le trouve
il garde la jauge au même
au même endroit
contre le plug c'était pas facile dame
B7 alors j'aurais pas compris que ça
marchait évidemment tu reprends des
sisters
puis on prend un 4
temps
E7
ça a l'air de passer je jette
c'est bien joué dame
ça passe pas
l'idée c'était de faire pion prend pour
prendre des 8 et sur dame prend B6 qui
est tombé
puis on prend ça on reprend des lits qui
allait prendre ses 8
j'aurais tenté mais bon ça marchait
probablement pas
ici on complique là
oh
recette la jauge qui monte
après aussi
sur des 5 cavaliers 5
on va pouvoir commencer à se masser
et là il y a pas cavalier 7
tours
7 qui va lire à 6
ah il veut cavaler B7 tours à 7
OK et cavaliers F6 soit j'allais le dire
et 5 maintenant pour s'installer sur
absolument toutes les cases noires de
l'échiquier
il y a peut-être du Tour C3 aussi qui
est intéressant pour aller taper colonne
C
il a fait G5 ça paraît assez logique
pour ces trois ça donne relativement
envie sur ton front F4 il y a cavalier
D3 je suppose ah mais il y aurait tours
C4
pas de bol ça donc tu reprends F4
cavalier prend aussi la vitesse de
calcul est assez impressionnante
côté Wesley
donc elle a compris il prend aussi
sur roi tours 5 ça semble un peu culotté
mais il va le tenter
ah YVES SAINT croit en G5 maintenant
attendez surtout un roi F5 fois 3 rois
G5 cavalier H7 il y avait roi H6 et
c'est terrible ça mais il fait fout des
trois il tient les cases alors peut-être
vous prend FC il veut peut-être tourner
intermédiaire
ton rêve 2 il se donne la case F4 pour
le roi un échec pour pour Ali une tour
en C7 on reprend G5 cavaliers H7
roche 6 rouages 5 tours H1 il va y avoir
foi 3 non roi G3 qui est G5 qui repart
faut 5 tours F7 il y a peut-être une
fourchette qui peut arriver ouais non il
se fait
il se fait
laminer à les raisins ouais j'ai peur
que le match soit long en fait j'ai peur
que Wesley soit ouais nettement plus
fort il a mis le il a mis le turbo
un peu comme comme contre les vannes
turbo d'entrée
allez il a quand même récupéré un punto
là le prince la jauge c'est la jauge
c'est vraiment un peu c'est vraiment
elle est pas elle était pareil elle
donnait - 2 tout à l'heure
cette jauge ne vaut rien elle a
absolument aucun coup c'est terrible là
il va peut-être y avoir pion prend
est-ce qu'il peut prendre mettre la tour
en B3 et stand il va tenter
ton B4 ouais deux rois et stand
et ce qui peut résister et prouver qu'il
existe
je crois qu'il prouve qu'il existe là
il résiste ah ouais il résiste de fou il
menace pour BK il va refaire un
aller-retour
oh bah ça revient en B3
bien joué Ali
allez ah on peut pas faire tour de trop
attention quand même il va lui faire un
petit Beko à trop à un moment donné
mais il résiste à
vérifie qu'il soit pas en train de se
prendre un set up je pense qu'il va
essayer de ramener le roi derrière il
veut passer par derrière avec le roi
Wesley
mais il arrive pas vraiment
à qui tient
bien joué à lui
il force les changes de tour
ah
les raisins qui s'est fait piéger
il s'est fait piéger bon bah ça fait
déjà un zéro pour
c'est terrible début de match difficile
c'est une partie qu'on aurait espéré à
tenir très franchement
et ça fait un zéro
pour essayer
c'est quoi ton sur les deux je peux pas
j'en sais rien là honnêtement trop dur à
dire là il y a trop de facteurs qui
rentrent en compte pour pouvoir donner
un pronostic
je sais pas je pense qu'elle est resa
est plus fort de base mais je sais pas
avec ce format je sais pas
ouais pas évident ouais c'est quand même
hyper fort en speechers
est quand même battu Wesley l'an dernier
mais ouais c'était dans des conditions
de jeu
en femme
et Maxime avait gagné de justesse
c'est avec la tempête de neige
donc c'est difficile à dire j'ai du mal
à jauger le niveau en pleine possession
de ses moyens doit se laver mais il est
vraiment fort
donc bien joué
ça
donc le cavalier est bien placé au
centre sur le 4 des 3 4 d'un point 4 tu
veux peut-être continuer avec fouder 6
et rock et 38
quand il a l'air de savoir ce qu'il veut
le prince
encore 75 minutes de 5 + 5 exactement et
j'y pousse tu comprends tu comprends les
règles encore 75 minutes
et après ça passera aux trois plus cinq
et un peu la cadence le moment pivot du
match
il faut prendre des sept dame prend des
7 et F3
c'est pas qu'elle est l'idée
à trouver mais j'ai pas trouvé bon je
vais regarder par curiosité
on sait pas si simple il était grand
rock puis on prend un cadre et jouer
l'activité ouais donc il y avait rien de
direct
qu'est-ce que j'aimerais qu'il fasse du
chest boxing tout cela
alors figeant les joueurs d'échec pro
comme les boxeurs pro font pas de chasse
boxing en fait
c'est pas des sports qui vont très bien
ensemble en fait à vrai dire
c'était genre d'échec pro
pas grand intérêt de se prendre des
coups sur la tête quoi
pas globalement quoi que tu fasses dans
la vie se prendre des coups sur la tête
c'est pas forcément le meilleur conseil
que tu puisses avoir
pas trop intérêt à perdre des séries tu
as pas trop intérêt à perdre tes
capacités cognitives ouais pour rien
derrière la boxe
à vrai dire
à vrai dire c'est un sport étrange
qui va faire pousser 5
suivis de petit rock j'aime bien les
Noirs c'est actif
je trouve que il est bien sorti à lire
il a beaucoup d'activités
d'un point de vue pratique c'est
tellement simple à jouer avec les Noirs
F4 ça a l'air d'être une bonne décision
ça laisse le pion passer mais il est
bloqué pour le moment
elle donne quasiment 0-0 elle abuse
paraît tellement bien pour les Noirs ça
dame C7 on va décaler taper le pion on
peut avoir dame B6 dame prend B2
peut-être
ça a l'air sympa
OK
c'est aussi pas idiot parce que s'il
veut il veut taper sur A2 en fait
ce qu'on va faire cavalier C7 cavalier
aussi si si
c'est pour essayer de taper un coup
cavalier ouais ou le mettre en
lumière aussi ce que ça tapait sur F4
aussi mais bon
ok intéressant ce dame B5 qui tape voilà
c'est cavaliers ici c'est sûr
il faut retrouver du lion dans les
pièces quoi
c'est intéressant ce que vient de faire
Wesley
alors sur cavalier prend F5 il doit
avoir un trick c'est ton dessin qui a
pas d'imprent des 5 d'un prendre des
cinq cavalier 7 le cavalier tient
c'est mieux pour
pour les Noirs c'est sûr
c'est sûr que ça avantage noir après
est-ce qu'il va réussir à convertir ça
c'est une autre question
on va essayer qui a joué comme quelques
coups vraiment intéressant
mais elle est résa a réussi à stabiliser
son avantage là
il a gagné la case D3 pour sa tour il
tape il tape le cavalier
de manière forte et il peut peut-être
regarder sur des dames des six dans F4
ici
donc il vient protéger le pion proposer
l'échange des dames
et son plan maintenant c'est réussi
c'est jouer sur la colonne D
pas facile à gagner
bon le droit de arriver vite en E6 pour
protéger le pion libérer le cavalier
essayez après d'utiliser la colonne D
il doit pas y avoir le temps de faire un
tour des deux
on a le plan de faire FG hgh5 aussi si
on rentre dans une finale de cavalier
on n'est pas loin d'un bel avantage
mais le cavaliers
et là je me demande si on peut faire
tout reprendre fghgh5
cette idée d'aller chercher le d'aller
changer l'avantage
alors il veut rentrer dans la finale
est-ce qu'après cavalier prend roi prend
G5 H4
le pion qui vient en B3 et A4 il pourra
rentrer
pour moi normalement non d'ailleurs
c'est ce que je joue Wesley ça
normalement pour moi il fait B3 il tient
voilà il va prendre
il va prendre et mettre les pions à 4 B5
le roi pourra jamais s'en approcher
il fait ses quatre
ok ouais au pire il fait ses seins et on
apprend
et ça c'est nul allez resa qui a laissé
passer sa chance
il a pas il a pas été assez précis dans
dans la finale
après il faut dire que ça joue vraiment
bien côté
il avait que deux secondes trop mal au
temps c'est pas faux mais après
dans la position
globale je sais pas trop comment
l'appeler mais
au début de la position où il a
clairement eu un avantage il avait quand
même autant voir plus de temps que que
Wesley et il a juste pas
réussi à l'utiliser quoi
complexe en tout cas
une petite italienne j'ai quasiment
envie de dire la plus simple on essaye
même pas de faire ces trois des quatre
mais le cavalier en dessin bon ça c'est
un peu j'ai envie de dire c'est jouer à
l'ancienne
ça ressemble à un endroit inversé alors
pas inversé mais un Londres
inversé mais de gauche à droite ouais
énormément de choses pour le moment
bon ça joue pour le moment
elles sont pas mal
prise du centre pour aller résa
jouer moi je trouve qu'elles sont dures
enfin c'est les positions que les
débutants ont souvent mais qui en
réalité sont très difficiles à jouer
c'est assez paradoxal
c'est en soi assez paradoxal
là comme vous voyez il attaque plutôt à
l'aile dame
mais bon c'est vraiment pas simple à
jouer il y a beaucoup de plans possibles
je trouve que c'est vraiment vraiment
pas évident
parce que là ça ressemble maintenant
plutôt à une instinienne dans l'esprit
bon même si les seins c'est pas la
question mais
je trouve que pour des gens qui débutent
les échecs c'est trop compliqué en fait
tous les tous les plans toutes les
possibilités qu'il y a
c'est ouais c'est position qui sont
dures alors que ouais on dit souvent
jouer l'italienne pour commencer après
c'est bien ça prend bien les échecs mais
c'est dur à jouer je vous raconte plutôt
de tenter les plans avec ces 3D 4 si
vous jouez l'italienne que vous
commencez c'est plus
de prise du centre quoi
sinon les positions elles sont trop
riches et voyez vous retrouvez là vous
débutez les échecs franchement
comment avancer pareil pour un débutant
je recommanderais ces 3D 4 ici aussi
pour prendre le centre quoi
mais là tous les plans qui font c'est
trop trop difficile à envoyer ils ont
poussé à l'aile dame on sait pas trop
enfin on sait pas trop pourquoi on sait
pourquoi mais je veux dire jusqu'à un
certain niveau c'est vraiment pas clair
de voir ce que les Blancs veulent faire
en poussant leur pion ici quoi
elle est noir vous allez voir qu'ils
vont faire F4 j'ai 5
G4 enfin bref six mettre le mettre leur
tour et pousser de ce côté là en tout
cas c'est ce qui prépare pour le moment
il se garde la flexibilité de jouer et
puis on prend pourra peut-être un jour
lui servir à sacrifier en F3
qui sait en tout cas il garde
l'incertitude il peut peut-être faire un
plan avec ton rêve 7 tours et venir
menacer
en tout cas Wesley qui est mieux autant
et qui semble simplement dominé à
l'IRESA un petit peu comme dans son
match président contre les vannes il
fait un énorme début de match Wesley
il va essayer d'écraser à l'IRESA au
début prendre trois quatre points
d'avance après gérer pendant trois
heures
on va voir s'il y arrive
diffuse qui prend l'espace ouais c'est
exact mais
comprendre à quoi sert la prise d'espace
en réalité à 800 hello ça me paraît
impossible
c'est trop abstrait
bah d'ailleurs là on voit bien il prend
de plus en plus d'espace mais au final
il donne de l'espace aussi quoi
donc là la manière dont il joue
l'italienne avec les Blancs c'est très
intéressant
mais voilà c'est un énième exemple de
pourquoi l'italienne me semble difficile
à jouer quand on débute après c'est une
bonne ouverture formatrice ça c'est pas
là n'est pas la question
mais là on voit les Noirs finalement
c'est eux qui mettent les pions au
centre et ils poussent ils poussent ils
poussent mais les pions peuvent devenir
des faiblesses donc là sur qui est
français si si doit avoir une idée qui
m'échappe une nouvelle fois je suis pas
en grande forme
après c'était juste d'attaquer le
cavalier de récupérer ces 7 ça va
peut-être pas plus loin que ça
même probablement
donc il prend et des 4
ouais la position elle semble
comment ça devenir intéressantes pour
pour les Noirs les pions sont trop
avancés et ils vont se faire contrer par
tomber 5 tour B8 donc exemple parfait
les prises d'espace maintenant avec
Alpha zero évidemment on vous montre
beaucoup de parties où ça marche on est
là en mode ouais c'est tout le temps
bien mais il se trouve que parfois on
peut faire ce que on appelle en anglais
tout over externe c'est prendre trop
d'espace et du coup ça laisse de
l'espace fit derrière c'est un peu comme
pour parler foot ouais si vous jouez
tous devant enfin tu vas pas mettre 11
cascuta sur le terrain
même si c'est un joueur exceptionnel un
cas plus tard c'est pas c'est pas la
question mais si tu en mets 11 sur le
terrain pas 10 on va dire 10 joueurs de
champ
bah disons qu'il touche le ballon et
tout il est il est créatif et c'est un
excellent meneur de jeu mais
ça va pas aller quoi
c'est comme Napoléon face à cruzza faut
être reprise d'espace mais c'est un peu
ça ouais et finalement il se fait
contrer
surtout qu'il est super nul que plus
tard numéro 10 comme Kakuta attention
et là il va peut-être y avoir du dames
C3 qui fait peut-être très mal avec le
pion qui va être
très bien placé
ah les raisins qui prend le bouillon
ouais
les raisins sur cette partie se fait
simplement écraser
bon voilà c'est ces deux tour B8 c'est
hyper simple
et c'est deux si c'est roi F1 c'est pour
C8 c'est un fou B2
ça va être trouvé il réfléchit mais
c'est trouvé évidemment
je trouve qu'au final le système de
Londres est plus facile à jouer que
il veut fermer
mon tour des 8 tour D1
malins qui fait mais un simple fou B2
gagne
E7 est pour 8
un simple fouet de gagne après il
cherche s'il y a pas mieux
aussi en fait
et ça fait ça fait deux points d'écart
déjà
le match pour être long pour aller
raisin ouais c'est qui a fait un départ
canon
je vous avais dit avant le match avant
le début du match on suit les speechs
ici on suit la compétition et je savais
que le je vous ai dit il peut mettre le
turbo en début de match à Wesley et
après et après gérer
et c'est le cas
et c'est exactement le scénario du match
malheureusement
c'est le scénario qu'on souhaitait
éviter
les raisins qui fait encore un
un bon début de partie
donc là une est indienne mais qui
finalement
ne ressemble pas trop à une est indienne
on sait qu'il va le rattraper en belette
j'ai pas les classements est-ce que
quelqu'un dans le chat a les classements
belette des deux joueurs
puis dans les 900 hello j'essaie de me
mettre au système de Londres avec ton
speedrun je trouve compliqué j'ai
l'impression d'être fragile de partout
mais j'adore alors le système de Londres
c'est hyper solide
si tu es fragile c'est pas forcément lié
aux échecs ou à l'ouverture attention
quand même
système de Londres c'est une ouverture
très solide quand même
ouais la position un peu bizarre là
il y a ce pion passé isolé là qui
c'est pas piqué des hannetons
le système de Londres ouais bah après
c'est très pleut très
mais c'est
si quelqu'un a vraiment pas trop de
temps investir dans les échecs c'est pas
mal pourquoi commencer aussi peut-être
pas au tout début mais à 700 800 Hello
on voit qu'il se retrouve moins bien
autant dans toutes ces parties
ouais ouais le turbo j'ai même envie de
dire Wesley mais le paquet
en ce début de match
on va voir
trois points d'écart c'est c'est pas
rédhibitoire parce que on connaît les
qualités
intrins secs d'aller Reza c'est pas
comme hier avec vous cash qui est quand
même
deux trois tons en dessous en blitz en
tout cas
mes trois points c'est beaucoup à ce
niveau là
c'est vraiment beaucoup c'est c'est un
vrai écart deux points ça c'est une
grosse différence entre plus de plus 3
je trouve
parce que plus de temps gagnent une bam
tu en gagnes une deuxième égalises + 3
tu en gagnes 2 il y a encore un point de
ouais c'est pas pareil en fait il y a
une différence entre plus et plus 3
c'est tu reviens un petit passage à vide
tu peux perdre deux parties consécutives
mais t'en perdras pas trois sur un
passage à vide quoi il y a une vraie
différence
c'est pas un truc complètement débile
que j'étais en train de dire en fait pas
ça semblait être complètement débile
mais ça l'est pas
ça avait une tête de phrase débile mais
ça l'était pas enfin pas tant que ça
ça l'était un peu un peu seulement donc
il revient jouer hyper tactique mais
surtout regardez la pendule hein je
j'insiste un peu dessus parce que le
les deux minutes elles sont pas
anecdotiques de différence
près le prince a déjà eu un match
difficile contre Dima qui était
nettement moins fort
que Wesley
c'est ça qui m'inquiète un peu
ouais très très facile il rigole il est
il est souriant quasiment un peu
chambreur
ouais qui est un peu dépassé en ce début
de match
j'avais pas en forme il me perdu un
match de [__] contre Slimane ouais ouais
il est pas il a pas il a pas l'air bien
voici la qui fait des petits des petits
signes de tête
match un peu un peu décousu un peu pris
à l'envers en fait par Ali Rosa
mais qui semble réellement moins fort
qu'il y a un an à l'IRESA je sais pas
trop
ce qui lui arrive
parce qu'il fait simplement moins
d'échec qu'avant mais on sent qu'il est
pas en progression
donc il couvre simplement la
la case c'est 7
dame prend des cinq tour à D8 qui a
validé 6 ça a l'air d'être le même il
fait roi H1 il s'enlève des cavaliers F4
d'avoir une idée sur tout rat des 8
mais il a juste joué tellement lentement
à l'IRESA enfin le problème de cette
partie c'est juste qu'il a plus de temps
tu peux pas rester avec 5 secondes
contre un avec plus une seconde contre
un joueur du calibre de wesleon
normalement
c'est juste pas possible en fait
c'est juste pas possible ce qu'il fait
fin c'est là la pollution j'ai pas si
elle est problématique ou pas on voit la
jauge qui s'affole un peu mais c'est ça
veut rien dire mais pour moi le le
déficit de temps il est juste criminel
en fait peut pas jouer avec 4 secondes 9
contre 3 minutes contre un joueur du
calibre de s.es.o ça passe contre moi
mais
à partir d'un certain niveau ça passe
plus
et ici est mis tout seul comme un grand
dans le problème à l'IRESA Wesley a pas
posé de problème outre mesure il était
pas sous pression d'accord il a essayé
de trouver des coups pour faire mal à
lire et ça il a pas jeté son temps pour
absolument rien mais ok à un moment
donné il faut jouer
qui prend prend et là il a sa F7 en un
mais
c'est pas vraiment qui laisse le pion en
un c'est que
il est obligé de jouer tout tempo quoi
ouais
[Musique]
il va le tenter maintenant
mais bon j'ai 4 ouais
et ça me prend des 5 ça fait trois
points d'écart ça fait cher ça fait cher
parce que là pour moi c'est c'est
vraiment un point donné
je me répète mais certes ouais ça a fait
une bonne partie c'est pas la question
mais quand tu te mets aussi mal au temps
enfin c'est vraiment l'équivalent de la
donnée
on peut pas on peut pas remonter une
partie comme ça c'est pas on peut pas
jouer avec si peu de temps contre un
joueur du top mondial comme comme West
les saut
en tout cas on sent que si on compare le
allié résa firuja qu'on avait il y a
deux ans à l'approche du Grand Suisse et
celui d'aujourd'hui
Ali resa il y a deux ans semblait
simplement plus fort on a vraiment
l'impression que quelqu'un IRESA est en
stagnation
mais
[Musique]
ça correlle avec tout ce qu'on a dit
pareil tout ce qu'on a dit avec tout ce
que tout ce qu'elle a dit résa a dit
stagnation on régression
on peut rien terme économiste c'est
peut-être une stackflation que noble de
côté quota lireza peut-être que lui ne
joue pas moins bien qu'il y a deux ans
mais stagné à haut niveau c'est
c'est régresser
on verra on aura une
vraie réponse à mon avis au grand Suisse
mais clairement si ce calcipoque
candidat ce sera forcément une grosse
déception
ce qu'on pensait que ces premiers
candidats sera un échauffement et que
les candidats 2024 ils seraient déjà à
la bataille pour la première place
à l'heure actuelle on commence à douter
de sa participation même
donc là on a une position typique un des
Italiens ou les Noirs ont décidé de
jouer avec hachis G5 c'est à la mode en
dernièrement on avait vu notamment André
Kid a beaucoup d'employé contre Alireza
dans son premier match
Mali a pas spécialement l'air bien
non il a dit qu'il serait sur son live
alors c'est pas lui qui décide si je
voulais candidats j'aime qui 27
il peut vouloir y aller mais c'est pas
lui qui décide
avec sa structure alors normalement
c'est plus pour jouer avec grand rock
quand même mais il peut arriver de faire
petit rock avec cette structure aussi
ouais
je sais pas ce que ça donne des
cavaliers prend ou des dessins pour tout
sortir ça paraît déjà quand même
agréable pour les noirs
ils ont peut-être égaliser déjà
bon il commence par dessin je sais pas
s'il veut prendre G3 ou pas il fait
cavalier F5 ça a l'air d'autant plus
intéressant parce que faut prends pion
prend à me prendre un recettes ça a pas
l'air de nager à grand chose
et là il menace de jouer qui a éponger 3
je prends j'ai trois qui est étrange
et taper avec le fou
c'est pour ça qu'il a pas pris tout de
suite en fait le fou est condamné il
faut prendre le cap n'est pas un
problème donc c'est pour ça que c'est
très bien joué de la part de West qui
vient pas croquer le fouger 3
directement il le laisse il le laisse en
suspens
et il le prend quand il veut un de toute
façon il a pas de d'échappatoire
elle est resa qui est de nouveau
supplice alors qu'on a une très très
belle caméra de Wesley sceaux qui
apporte vraiment beaucoup
un truc c'est que si on fait roi H1 pour
jouer j'ai ouais on peut jouer ouais GF
ouais mais
non on peut pas parce qu'il y avait les
projets
FG ouais c'est d'une tristesse
ça peut déjà faire plus 4 pour aller
résa ça peut être la douche froide
ça peut être la douche froide
alors la bonne nouvelle pour aller Raisa
c'est qu'il va y avoir une pause là on
est à la on va arriver à la mi-temps du
5 + 1 donc on va voir une une première
pause dans ce match qui va qui va
peut-être lui faire du bien allez faudra
aller à la pause à -3 pas moins 4
ouais c'est qui est très facile et on
voit un de nouveau le même défaut un
chalet resa là qui réfléchit beaucoup
mais on peut le comprendre là parce que
il a le choix entre mal et pire
dis dans le chat le Bullet peut le
sauver ouais mais faut attaquer le
Bullet à moins de -3 on va pas falloir
rater à - 5 - 6
pour essayer qui est pas du tout en
gestion pour le moment ce serait bien
qu'il commence à rentrer en mode
gestionnaire et qui maintiennent un
écart de moins de moins 3 qui nous
donnerait une chance de revenir en force
en belette mais à l'heure actuelle
il veut faire enfler le score ouais
c'est il est bien au courant du danger à
lire et ça
cavalier des quatre jouets
peut-être pas un mauvais coup d'ailleurs
les raisins dans sa
moi je veux voir sur son écran de
contrôle il est en train de regarder des
trucs en fait il regarde même plus la
partie là il est en train de regarder
des
il est en train de naviguer sur la
player list à lire les regarde même pas
là game
si c'est bien son écran à lui
je sais pas si c'est son écran ou pas
je crois que c'était lui hein je crois
pas que c'était sauf que c'était à lui
de jouer il était juste en train de
regarder des listes de classement et
l'eau ah il en a absolument rien à faire
en fait
ça navigue en fait c'est ouais c'est sur
le navigateur et ça clique à côté
aussi si il veut donner la case de 5
pour le fou
match horrible pour pour aller résa
allez sauver un demi point ici je sais
pas comment honnêtement position est
difficile mais peut-être cavalier c'est
trois il y a de me prendre des quatre
alors la jauge est pas si effrayé
ce qu'on prend E4 on va peut-être
récupérer encore un pion de l'autre côté
il regarde la voile tard ouais belle
étape aujourd'hui du côté de la Vuelta
c'est compliqué à regarder cette année
cette Volta
on se demande si la Jumbo vis ma va
réussir à faire le quadrupley Pourquoi
Pas l'année prochaine viser top 4 voire
même top 5 pourquoi pas aller encore
plus loin
oui il prend des cartes et tout prendre
qu'il y a eu 4 grands quoi ça pas la
position parure il prend ses sept il est
interdit le grand rock c'est quand même
déjà ça
tourne c'est 8 il va faire dames prends
des cartes il faut prendre des quatre
fois cinq F5
ah non la position est kata
le pion va arriver en F5 ça va être ça
va être un pion de moins net et clean
il peut même pas décaler la dame il y
avait d'enfant des 6 et là il va faire
dame prend tour reprend et roi F7 tour
des 8
ça va faire 4 points d'écart
pour
abandonne carrément et là ça va être on
demande un temps mort mais ouais c'est 4
et demi un demi un match
aux allures de du match qu'on a qu'on a
suivi hier c'est
ouais j'ai pas les mots on s'y attendait
vraiment pas et à lire Elsa qui semble
désabusé un de l'autre côté
il part
rapidement de de son ordinateur on va
prendre une petite respiration une
petite pause de notre côté aussi mais
début de match plus qu'inquiétant on a
du mal à voir à lireza revenir dans ce
match après ce que la pose peut lui
permettre de retrouver son énergie et de
de remettre de se remettre les idées en
place on aura la réponse dans 5 minutes
à tout de suite les amis
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title
tuesday.com/avent scoop tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez en direct
les parties des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète avec les commentaires en
français de nos experts notre moteur
d'analyse l'explorateur d'ouverture et
les tables bases retrouvez toutes les
infos essentielles comme le programme
les horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats des comptes rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
les amis on est de retour
le match doit reprendre
ça va pas encore repris
bon ça ouais je pensais que ça allait
que ça allait reprendre tout de suite en
fait quand je suis revenu je sais pas
pourquoi c'est encore en pause
d'ailleurs c'est bizarre qu'il soit pas
là après il a pas l'air il perd
alors je sais pas si c'est en forme ou
concerné par le match mais il y a
quelque chose qui tourne par an
je crois que tout le monde est étonné en
fait
match un peu bizarre qui est dans un
forêt
il est pas bien fierou ouais après ça se
peut aussi que il soit pas il soit plus
pas giga concerné par le truc
possible aussi un qui sentent pas
vraiment concerné par par le tournoi
pour une raison qui nous a connu vous
êtes il a déjà l'horaire du match est
bizarre
je sais pas pourquoi ça se joue un mardi
à 15h en fait vu j'ai pas trop compris
l'horaire à vrai dire
c'est pas l'horaire le plus logique
mais il est encore sur une autre fenêtre
ah ouais elle est Raisa en fait il est
réellement sur d'autres fenêtres pendant
les parties ouais c'est bien lui il fait
autre chose en fait
premier degré en fait là il est il est
pas en train de ouais ouais il navigue
sur sur d'autres trucs en fait
ah il en a vraiment
il va faire exprès de perdre les excuses
svp c'est pas des excuses c'est juste ou
peut-être qu'il s'en fiche en fait j'ai
pas
obligé de faire exprès de perdre en fait
tu as peut-être juste rien à faire enfin
c'est possible
tu as une justice comme ça et voilà ça
se passe bien ça se passe bien ça se
passe mal
ça lui en touche une sans faire bouger
l'autre quoi
enfin c'est un peu son attitude générale
vis-à-vis des échecs dernièrement
en tout cas vu de l'extérieur après on
sait pas peut-être qu'il prépare les
échéances en partie longue à fond en ce
moment et qu'il est pas forcément
dans le mood pour jouer parce que jouer
c'est quand même quelque chose de
particulier je sais pas trop comment
dire si vous êtes en train de faire des
grosses sessions d'entraînement par
exemple c'est possible que vous soyez
pas très performant dans le jeu
parce que la pratique est le et
l'entraînement c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose
par contre donc je vous assure c'est
qu'il navigue sur moi de ce que je vois
enfin de ce que je comprends en tout cas
tu peux me tromper mais de ce que je
vois il arrive vraiment qu'il navigue
sur
sur son ordi
alors qu'est-ce qui regarde ça j'arrive
pas à voir mais
de la bonne musique sur Spotify je sais
pas ce qu'il fait très franchement je
sais pas ce qu'il fait mais
non c'est pas la Vuelta j'ai
l'impression que c'est sur chiasse com
mais je sais pas ce qu'il fait
en tout cas il triche pas
ça c'est sûr
en tout cas il triche pas ça c'est sûr
non les échecs c'est un jeu c'est
vraiment dur de jouer des fois en plus
tu as l'impression que tu vas bien jouer
tu vas mal jouer c'est c'est compliqué
c'est particulier
il a joué F3
solide
je pense qu'il avait peur de trucs à
base de Québec 4 et de se faire rentrer
sur les cases blanches après
Wesley
je pense qu'il veut juste visser sur la
case de 4
on va essayer ce qui va y arriver pas
sur ce bien que quand même pour un peu
de le suspense du match Carly résa la
Garenne celle-là qui reviennent un peu
au score quand même parce que sinon ça
va vraiment être comme hier et c'est
long
ok là pour moi la dynamique du match un
peu changé en termes de réflexion elle
est là faut vraiment se jeter sur
cavalier c'est 5 on peut caler H4
intermédiaire si on veut mais allez
rentrer sur les cases là pas laissé B4
au blanc
leur dire a pas l'air effrayé par B4
mais quand même
cavalier 5 revenir un peu jaillir là
faire quelque chose
alors il a fait H4 H3 bon ça va là il
crée des menaces de l'autre côté ça
laisse pas vraiment le temps au blanc de
faire B4 ils doivent réagir
peut-être par G3 mais allez là une bonne
partie
et peut-être quand même revenu avec
d'autres ambitions
donc il fait j'ai 4
ouais bon
il va se ramener un cavalier en E4 et
reprendre du fond F3 je sais pas ce que
ça vaut
il fait 3 d'accord il recontrôlent les
gars en fait il faut éviter faut H6 là
Wesley allez là il y a une bonne une
bonne partie il faut la gagner
franchement je pense que s'il gagne pas
celle-là avec les Noirs au moins facile
à faire s'il fait nul bon il y aura
quand même encore un espoir mais super
ça avec les Noirs je pense que c'est fin
du match
je pense que c'est la fin du match parce
que c'est la première bonne position
qu'il a avec un avantage au temps si
même là il réussit pas à faire l'écart à
mon avis il y arrivera jamais donc faut
vraiment qu'il a gagné après Wesley
déjà tu mettes la pression et qui
perdent pas
donc toi il vient se placer colonel
ça peut vite tourner quand même c'est
parti la pion prend cavalier prend
cavalier H4 ça peut aller vite
d'un côté comme de l'autre
ouais c'est complexe c'est complexe
peut-être amener ce cavalier en C5 pour
essayer quand même de jaillir
tous ces deux sont pas être une option
malheureusement
il va juste décaler la dame et on
accomplit rien avec avec ce fou ces deux
malheureusement
puis on prend on l'a rayé de notre liste
des cours
mais après il faut trouver quoi faire
après B4 aussi
mais ce qu'on vient vers 17 ou est-ce
qu'on va vers D3 en tout cas c'est ce
que doit être en train de calculer les
raisins
alors il a joué tout reste
bon c'est pas idiot comme quoi donc
c'est pas mal joué aussi
il doit pas y avoir de problème en
réalité sur des pions-pran G4 pour le
moment pour prendre du cavalier
peut-être qu'il va jouer cavalier CE4
ouais c'est allez en tout cas c'est
Wesley qui est en difficulté dans cette
partie
il joue cavalier D24
et un côté plus logique parce que c'est
cavalier C3 est mieux placé il y a un
côté moins logique dans le sens où le
cavalier des protéger le pur F3 mais si
considère que sur pion prend il fait fou
prendre dans tous les cas c'est assez
logique
au final une 14 contre une 18 allée resa
qui est un petit peu mieux autant mais
cet avantage temporel va disparaître
prise de 4 prise 4 du pion maintenant
attention on a on s'est fait
condamné les ouvertures de jeu
et les Blancs ont peut-être le temps de
faire B4 maintenant pour condamner le
cavalier
puis après améliorer petit à petit leur
position c'est potentiellement Wesley
qui réussit une nouvelle fois à prendre
l'avantage
pas position et pas clair
cavalier
pas probablement à cause de fous des
trois ou Dame des trois j'en ai pas
parlé
mais ouais B4 maintenant qui arrive à 6
qui a jamais atterri sur la case C5
finalement et regardez comme il est mal
placé il va devoir revenir via B8 en D7
mais si ce match weekend c'est un aveu
de faiblesse position n'est pas encore
perdante pour les Noirs mais ça donne
l'impression de petit à petit
s'améliorer pour les blancs
et les blancs pourront essayer de jouer
plus tard avec ces 5
dans la position ici et avantageuse pour
pour Wesley maintenant ouais non s'il y
a une salade
ça va être long
et là il est en train de tanquer donc
elle va aller B8 jouer mais bon on
comprend que ça va pas les blancs
peuvent notamment jouer juste vous
prendre à 7 cavalier 17 suivi de fou et
3 alors il fait tout reprendre F6 et
foutran G4 et il rate Tour Eiffel prise
à fin prise à fin et d'un projet 4 allez
grosse gaffe de Wesley qui donne une
pièce en un coup
Wesley qui donne une pièce en un coup
énormément gaffe du joueur américain qui
s'incline incroyable celle-là ouais
c'est la c'est la première
ouais partie étonnante c'est ouais
depuis hier on a pas de on n'a pas de
chance avec les matchs on voit pas de
on voit pas de beau match en fait c'est
trop déséquilibré là c'est tant mieux
pour nous c'est pris mais c'est ensuite
une partie 10 minutes qui se termine sur
une pièce en un
ça remet si Ron en jeu c'est ça le côté
positif mais on a ouais le niveau de jeu
ne s'emballe pas pour le moment
étonnant
allez ça peut complètement remettre
fearuja dedans et faire douter Wesley
c'est quand même une énorme gaffe ce qui
vient de faire
donc il peut il peut se retrouver en
plein doute
on peut le voir le voir douter peut-être
donc on a de nouveau une italienne
on va voir si réussi à
en faire quelque chose
de cette petite italienne
enfin mettre un point avec avec les
Blancs
évidemment faire des grosses gaffes
comme ça ça peut ça peut faire douter
pour Wesley
donner une pièce en un ça fait jamais
plaisir
on a pas du tout les mêmes positions que
d'habitude
je suis pas trop spécialiste de ces
Italiens avec le cavalier qui se
retrouvent 7 un peu bizarre mais ça
évite de se prendre un clouage
franchement si elle y résa finissait ce
5 + 5 à 2 points d'écart ce serait déjà
un exploit
ce serait plutôt contre le cours du
match mais
ça ça relance en tout cas tout le
suspense
là c'est pas mal hein on tape F7 quand
même le pion A5 qui
permet de pas voir le coup cavalier à 5
arrivée
qui réfléchit
ça pas je pensais au début qu'on avait
du cavalier G5 mais il y a dame prend
enfin c'est pour essayer de faire [__]
cette fougères 6 mais ça va pas marcher
en fait il peut il pouvait il aurait pu
exister des ventes comme ça un peu
marrante
genre que j'espérais faire marcher mais
le problème c'est qu'il y a à Tours F1
mais je veux dire des trucs comme ça bon
peu importe ça marche pas du tout c'est
n'importe quoi
c'est du grand n'importe quoi il a fait
B6
peut pas tenter du [__]
il fait cavalier H4 que j'aime beaucoup
aussi
on a l'impression que ce pion est quand
même mis au supplice il va faire dame 8
et peut-être qu'avalière à trois
cavaliers 5
alors là c'est parti très bizarre
franchement elle est blanc semble être
super bien
si Wesley trouve pas d'écoute défense
très précis ça pourrait durer simplement
quelques coups
ça peut arriver de ce côté là et ça peut
arriver avec ton rêve de Tour Eiffel
qui veut quoi il veut redescendre avec
la dame ouais ça paraît
ça paraît compliqué
il veut Dame des 7 maintenant non mais
regardez la jauge c'est ridicule elle
donne 0-0 après de tels coups comme dame
8 cavalier D8 Dame des 7
comment ça peut être juste égal en fait
comment ça peut juste être égal ce truc
là
incroyable TV5 dames des 7 et égal
à l'ordi donne C6 cavaliers à 3 et D5
bon très franchement c'est
juste pas droit d'être cette évaluation
là
il y a juste aucun droit pour avoir
cette évaluation là
c'est fou
non mais là j'ai l'impression qu'il va
faire dames et 7 et que ça va aller
finalement pour les Noirs mais
enfin je sais pas les coups étaient
tellement
alambiqué que ça devait pas
ça devait pas passer mais les échecs
c'est étonnant parfois
on pense que ça va pas passer et ça
passe et des fois c'est l'inverse on
pense que ça va passer ça passe pas
c'est terrible
il ramène la tour en F1 il va tenter de
jouer avec E4 évidemment voilà il peut
pas jouer avec eux 4 en fait le fou est
venu en E6 donc il joue avec D4 mais le
cavalier à 3 il va devoir revenir vers
B5
mais on sent que les Noirs ont retrouvé
du lion là où il devait pas en trouver
et non
c'est le mot étonnant
là il est bien au temps en tout cas il
est revenu
par la partie d'avant elle est elle est
un peu en
cache misère parce qu'il devait la
perdre mais il est revenu quand même
avec un autre rythme de jeu à lire et ça
il joue il joue quand même plus vite et
il a l'air plus saignant que dans la
toute première partie du match là les 45
premières minutes où c'était
insignifiant là il joue CK à toi il met
il met pression
la pause la pause lui a fait du bien en
tout cas elle
le petit coup de bol aussi
et là c'est peut-être sa meilleure
partie
où elle sait qu'il y a la réussite mais
mais la partie a l'air quand même
relativement aboutie côté français
donc qui prend la tension à ne pas se
prendre un G5 un jour mais il y a des
soucis de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
il remet la dame en D1 sur G5 la
cavalier F5 évidemment ici il y a
peut-être de la dame qui arrive en H5
aussi
ça se passe ça se passe pas mal je
continue à penser que la position doit
être mieux pour aller Raisa
après tout ce qui a été joué
côté noir c'est ça Maker en fait
si c'est pas le cas
trop bizarre
trop bizarre que ça ne soit pas le cas
allez qui revient en B un verset 3 le
qui revient vers des 6 il revient en C3
qui peut reprendre même du pion
d'ailleurs peut-être
intéressant ce pion à tenir la case
c'est si cela dans certaines lignes
ça peut
car il prend et aussi possible ça
attaque la dame ça gagne un tempo les
deux les deux sont deux deux
possibilités
je prendrai plutôt du pion d'ailleurs
on sait jamais un jour il y a peut-être
un pion B6 qui tombe et on se rapproche
de dames
pour l'ordi les deux coups étaient
équivalents
j'ai l'impression que ce pion il peut
servir
on a bien joué F5
et ce fou est très bien placé un petit
couple la case F1 à la tour
donc il joue dans ma chambre c'est
logique
il va peut-être mettre le cavalier en G6
finalement il y aura pas de cloche parce
qu'au pire on prend on prend le 7 sur
échec donc et G6 qui est frangip6 dame
Pranger 6
ça passe ça passe crème
des Torres G3
le seul petit souci de la position c'est
qu'on a pas cette case à FM comme je le
disais
il y a peut-être un problème avec ce
pion dessin aussi finalement
ah c'est bizarre on n'arrive pas à
s'organiser
pour ces deux on a pas vraiment j'ai
l'impression
il fait H3 un coup qui mange pas de pain
qui donne une case au roi
il se fait prendre B5 dame 5 c'est
logique
touche le fou mais il revient en C4
et tout est défendu côté noir
peut-être dessin maintenant pour se
donner la case des 4 pour la dame
évidemment c'est pas le kiff de l'ordi
ça mais c'est un jeu pratique oh des
trois bien joué il coupe la colonne des
ah se fou et devenu hyper fort en fait
il coupe les tours du jeu regardez on
n'a pas la colonel pour doubler on a
plus la colonne des
et là les raisins qui essayent de casser
le genou mais en réalité il va se faire
contrer devant le rock ah et B5 bien
joué pour B4 allez le cavalier qui qui
va naviguer vers F4
il se fait échanger la dame qui prend
des seins qui revient en E5 alors cette
finale c'est quoi on a quoi on a deux
pions de moins on a un semblant
d'activité mais qui va pas être
suffisant il va prendre G4 jouer ton G5
ça va échanger ouais c'est la tour
arrive en B4 c'est terminé et ça refait
ça refait plus 4 et j'ai envie de dire
la réussite à l'écotale les raisins
parce que si c'était plus 6 là s'il
donne pas la pièce dans la partie
précédente Wesley il y a plus 6 et ce
serait ce serait déjà vraiment
complètement rideau l'envoi airesa qui
se lève qui se barre
il prend trop cher à lireza
alors ça a l'air d'être utile hein ce
que je vous disais regarde d'autres
d'autres onglets il est il est en tilt
il est en train juste de se faire masser
et là il a il a le seum il a le seum
Wesley a des raisins pardon il pourrait
quasiment jouer côté Belgique pour pour
notre match du SAM
parce que là on sent le seum puissant
est-ce qu'il est en train de rage quitte
le match
pense pas mais l'attitude est étonnante
là on sait pas trop ce qu'il fait c'est
il est pas parti 30 secondes ouvrir une
porte ça fait déjà une minute qui qu'il
est parti
alors il revient
et visiblement partie faire quelque
chose
Wesley qui va peut-être rendre le temps
voilà le match qui est complètement dans
un Forex
le match qui s'installe dans un forisme
on n'arrive pas à s'envoler dans ce
match
ouais ouais il est parti il est parti
dans son jardin il est parti
je sais pas ce qu'il est parti faire à
l'IRESA il a pas l'air dans son assiette
en tout cas sur l'échiquier
par petit taper dans un arbre
ouais ouais après c'est vrai qu'il y a
des manières de relâcher le stress là
quand il y en a trop dans des matchs
comme ça mais je pense pas qu'il ait eu
le temps là en une minute
voilà les joueurs ont tous ont tous leur
technique pour pour réussir rapidement à
évacuer à se soulager de la pression
après voilà peut-être que pourra lire ça
c'est c'était d'aller crier un bon coup
dans la cuisine
il y aura une plus longue pause là après
le 5 + 1
je pense pas que ce soit juste parti
pisser parce qu'il venait d'une la pose
la pose avait eu lieu 15 minutes avant
peut-être qu'il avait une livraison
Amazon ou un truc comme ça après
donc il est juste allé chercher un c'est
ça c'est le plus probable c'est qu'il
est il est juste allé ouvrir une
livraison
ou un deliveroo ou un truc comme ça
bon en tout cas pour reparler de la
partie
une nouvelle fois
ouais après moi je pense que je suis
reçu
une livraison et ça a pas plus loin
pas la peine de se faire des idées
peut-être commander un deliveroo un truc
comme ça
après moi pour voir leur caméra de
sécurité là par derrière c'est vrai que
l'endroit où je vois les raisins a pas
l'air très confortable mais bon après
c'est pas très confort
c'est top
table ronde avec une petite sieste avec
un petit un petit un petit siège ça a
pas l'air top après les jeunes
mais les gens sur une petite chaise
blanche avec un avec un dossier vraiment
très bas un genre de table ronde un peu
un peu zarbi
et chez sauce et comment
c'est assez triste aussi
ouais c'est assez triste des deux côtés
mais plus que tu as les arc côté
le matériel et un pion de plus là
c'était un peu comme un Benco ça a l'air
d'aller pour aller Raisa
bon 4 points d'écart rien n'est encore
réellement perdu
là il a de nouveau une position correcte
à l'IRISA c'est quand même il y a du
mieux
malgré la défaite un peu triste partie
précédente
on sent que la maison du Minnesota est
quand même grande
ouais mais il est pas sur la même setup
que d'habitude donc je ne sais pas à
vrai dire
malgré ça en fait sont son truc ça
ressent ouais je sais pas ça ressemble
un peu à des trucs je sais pas tu as
l'impression qu'ils jouent d'une chambre
d'hôtel quoi je sais pas comment dire
c'est pas des set up
de travail quoi
et saut juste un peu austère quoi c'est
un peu
c'est un peu froid quoi c'est tout
bon elle a une bonne position en
attendant il va pouvoir mettre une tour
en B4 mettre la pression le long de la
colonne B il y a ça ça joue ça joue
quand même mieux
ça joue quand même mieux
allez pièces blanches qui qui
travaillent pas en réalité vous voyez ce
footcent noir là qui va se réveiller et
qui va taper extrêmement fort sur B2
pour qu'on menace pour prendre B2 qui
prend B2
donc il y a quand même il y a quand même
un vrai travail là qui est fait côté
noir un vrai travail de sape
dame qui pourrait même peut-être rentrer
un jour en E2 d'ailleurs
là les noirs sont sont clairement mieux
allez faut revenir à trois points comme
je disais ainsi qu'il reste deux parties
il gagne ça là il gagne la prochaine il
revient à - 2 et
et on saura pas trop comment
il y avait les Détroit peut aussi être
une option à reboot là il y a beaucoup
d'options attention quand même quand tu
bouges ce cavalier tu donnes la casse C4
il peut commencer par H3 aussi pour un
peu affaiblir F3 h3g3 dame 2 par exemple
ça ça peut être un enchaînement
intéressant ou F2 qui prend F3
ou même dame prend des deux dames prends
des deux KF3 qui prend des deux après en
tout cas commencez par H3 c'est pas des
nuées de sens pour venir affaiblir G2 et
préparer dame de
ça pourrait être un coup extrêmement
logique d'un H3 et d'un suivi dame de
c'est ce qu'il joue d'ailleurs
la position est extrêmement difficile
pour
pour le prince
la position est vraiment très très
difficile pour le prince ici
donc il échange en G2
pour couvrir cette case de
3 et cavaliers C2
c'est solide d'un côté Wesley il réussit
pour le moment à mettre deux trois
barboles je demande si la tour elle peut
réussir à repartir ouais non ça c'est
trop typiquement les idées de débiles
que je peux avoir parfois
on n'arrive pas à la revenir via l'autre
côté attention plus que 23 secondes pour
pour aller résa plus de 20 secondes
attention par contre si elle tourne en
faveur de de Wesley celle-là ce sera le
mimi ce sera le rara ce sera la même
merde
qui vit en C4 attention il réussit à
échanger les dames là où c'est il est en
train de se tenir la nul
dommage de laisser filer un demi point
mais il faut pas en laisser filer plus
allez prends quand même en B3 cavalier
prend des 6 là la jauge s'enflamme mais
je comprends pas pourquoi très
franchement
tour B2 il va y avoir tout D2
il faut être fuite
alors est-ce que le problème c'est que
ce cavalier se retrouve un peu à
l'étroit
comment est-ce qu'il peut s'en sortir il
a plus de cases il a plus que c'est 8 il
fait F4 pour se gagner la casse C4
ah ça échange c'est plutôt bien joué et
cavalier à trois hauts la tour est
protégée par le fou
ah cette finale elle est juste
complètement égale il va y avoir foi F4
et cavalier C4 ça va faire nul bon il
fait 3 et cavaliers C4 quand même
bah je crois pour s'enlever le le roi de
la pression
il va quand même mettre le fond E3
peut-être il se fait changer oh il file
un pion là Wesley oh c'est pas une belle
fin de partie
il va ramener le pion jusqu'en H7
elle peut perdre celle-là le pion va
arriver en C3
FR4 c'est bien joué
mais il a pas le temps de toucher la
case des trois
ça moi j'aurais l'impression que ça perd
pour les blancs
il va faire faux F2 ouais c'était sûr
il va mettre le rang C2
ah il a [__] en C3
qu'est-ce que c'est bien défendu de la
part de Wesley très très fort
waouh comment il a réussi à passer le
fou d'un côté le roi de l'autre et il y
avait plus moyen de d'amener le bras
pour escorter F parce qu'il perdait C3
et ça faisait dame
waouh très très jolie défense de West
sur la pour le coup
allez c'est la première passe d'arme un
peu sympa du match je trouve la cette
finale
il y a une petite gaffe au début mais
après le la défense de West était très
élégante et donc ça va être la dernière
partie en 5 + 1 ce serait bien Cali
Raisa l'emporte
c'est d'aller chercher le Punto
ça nous mettrait extrêmement bien
ok on va vouloir jouer un pour B5 fou B7
côté Wesley
allez il faut il faut trouver les coups
à côté Ali resa
je m'en remets pas encore de la de la
défense
héroïque de wesle là dans la dans la
petite finale dans le petit jeu
c'est un excellent défenseur mais il
fallait un sang-froid
cryonique
pour y arriver peut-être que ça veut
rien dire mais vous m'avez quand même
compris
position on est très très bizarre c'est
une grue Feld
un peu un peu bionique
on est allé mettre des petits coups
d'attaque côté blanc à gauche à droite
on croit dit le rami ouais
c'est quand même un peu plus fort qu'a
dit le rami ouais c'est ça
malheureusement
malheureusement sinon le match serait
moins compliqué
pour Ali Raisa une nouvelle fois
j'allais vous dire il doit hésiter pour
H6 c'est ce qu'il a besoin de chasser ce
cavalier je pense qu'il va repartir vers
ok peut-être je sais pas s'ils ont un F3
les deux sont possibles là j'imagine que
6 pour venir fixer par leur dit propose
F5 ici
ouais peut-être option prend et rev5
c'est dur ça c'est fort ouais ouais
c'est vrai mais ça c'est des coûts c'est
tellement dur après je pense qu'un
Maxime
AMZ là le F5 à mon avis
à mon avis
ça c'est des coups pour Maxime
évidemment
ça c'est des coups
pour pas un coup
très difficile je pense pour un joueur
pur sang
de nashdorfd
il veut quoi il veut essayer de jouer
c'est F5 maintenant
pour ça qu'il y ait du 17 était pas
super ouais
ces positions tellement complexes
on sait pas trop
par où les prendre il refait le coup
elle est dure de nouveau ça là pour pour
aller raisin
et contrairement à son match contre les
vannes il est vraiment pas fuir sa proie
là ouais c'est
entre les Van il a toujours été en
contrôle mais on sent qu'il
connaît le danger que pourraient
représenter à l'IRESA quand la cadence
s'accélère
il veut pas vraiment pas lui donner
d'oxygène
il veut complètement l'empêcher de
respirer
ça tape regardez les pions qui sont
fragiles
j'ai 5 G4 voyez il y a la marée de pion
la qui arrive côté noir
elle iraita qui se retrouve moins bien
au temps maintenant finalement
ah ouais non faudrait faut pas la perdre
ça n'a pas tourné à -5 un score
à la goucache là
ah ouais là c'est
c'est dur
c'est dur à les cavaliers de fallait
bien le défendre du RX y ce pion mais
j'ai 5 vous voyez ça arrive il veut G4
et affaiblir le pion cette expansion à
la loi fait tellement mal et les pièces
blanches sont une nouvelle fois pas très
bien organisées regardez je mets les
pièces en rouge là la dame à 3 le
cavalier de le fouet fin
elle va faire peut-être pas faire aussi
pour se garder la case pour le fou
ouais
dans ces tournois
t'es pas loin de batterie car ou un dans
ce format une année car où c'est un peu
celui qui gagne tous les matchs mais il
avait réussi à le mettre en danger très
très dur à prendre Wesley
donc il joue dans le dessin
mais jouer contre ce pion des 4 faibles
il est grand sourire ouais c'est il est
facile il est très très facile
il s'attendait probablement un gros
combat aujourd'hui
mais pour le moment ce combat c'est lui
qui l'impose
et qui fait mal
qu'une dix pour pour aller résa avec une
nouvelle fois se retrouve en
difficulté à la pendule à la tour va
arriver en D8 ouais c'est les pièces
d'Ali resa regardez on avait dit ça dame
à trois mal placé elle se retrouve
maintenant D1 et regarder un COS lait
qui prend les priorités dans des 8 il
veut peut-être tenter un cavalier C3
il fait torder 8
avec une quarantaine de secondes
d'avance plus qu'une minute pour aller
résa alors après je vois dans le chat
que vous êtes très confiant pour les
bullets mais ok si peu gagner les
bullets de plus de plus 3 les raisins ce
sera déjà exceptionnel mais pour le
moment le retard est plus conséquent et
regardez la tour en D8 qui tape le pion
des 4 est cloué
ah ça peut tourner à moins 5 en ayant eu
le bol en plus de la gaffe de West ça
aurait pu faire moins 7 sur ce 5 plus 5
et ouais le problème c'est que dans le
contenu
il y en a qui aime beaucoup regarder des
sports comme comme le rugby parfois le
rugbyte est mené au score mais par
exemple
fidjias étaient nettement menés au score
mais dans le contenu on sentait qu'ils
étaient plus forts et donc ça peut
revenir là le problème c'est que non
seulement le score est et sévère mais
mais au-delà de ça dans le contenu on a
l'impression que le joueur américain
domine nettement donc lorsque c'est deux
facteurs s'additionnent l'un à l'autre
le score et le contenu on a du mal à
voir un retournement de situation après
les cadans vont les cadences vont
changer est-ce que ça permettra de
changer la dynamique du match on aura la
réponse dans deux heures de ça
mais ouais faut aussi se regarder les
pièces regardez juste les pièces
blanches alors il tente corriger 5 ça
fouger 5 ça a été raté
en tout cas l'idée a été raté c'est très
bien joué de la part d'Ali resa d'aller
tenter ça mais là ouais je suis fou
prends le 5 il y aura pas de cavaliers
F4
malheureusement vous prend le 5 et le
coup qui tue ici
retard de matériel et le matériel est
bien trop important bon là il tente des
seins qu'on sait pas trop pourquoi et il
abandonne Wesley qui est en train
d'écrabouiller à les raisins firuggia
dans un match pour le moment à sens
unique ouais c'est ça qui mène sur le
score très sévère mais mérité de 7
points à deux
mesdames et messieurs on va à bientôt se
se retrouver après
après la pause
mais
ouais c'est difficile franchement je
voulais rajouter quelque chose pendant
que je corrige une petite faute qu'on
avait sur le
sur le design mais ouais il y a rien à
ajouter match kataki
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts
et même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs émoticônes et les
emojis disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts spéciales restent sur les
chéquiers jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
effacées pour ce faire il suffit de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur l'emoji ou de cliquer sur le
bouton Tout effacer
[Musique]
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
les amis on est de retour
ça devrait bientôt reprendre
faut espérer que le 3 + 1
permet à les raisins de revenir un
changement de cadence on va vite être
fixé un de toute façon moins 5 c'est pas
assez pour enfin c'est trop
d'écart ou c'est pas assez proche ça
dépend comment vous placez le problème
pour revenir
le 3 + 1 c'est un moment charnière du
match évidemment
on va voir si elle est résa réussit à
revenir
ou pas
ou pas ou pas
on va avoir
complexe en tout cas
ils sont encore moins 3 je pense ouais
- 4 j'y croirais déjà pas mais il y a
peut-être un monde
c'est pas fini encore non parce que il y
a le changement de cadence ça continue
en 5 + 1 j'aurais pu espoir
mais là avec avec le changement de
cadence j'ai encore espoir
allez ça repart
à des raisins qui va avoir les pièces
noir
non c'est pas pourquoi western
OK
petite instinct de nouveau
et cavaliers à 6 OK
sur des cadences au-dessus de 3 plus X
alors ça peut-être mais après c'est
juste l'écart là qui est important c'est
pas c'est pas le fait que je pense pas
qu'elle ira soit capable de
revenir un petit peu juste cinq points
c'est beaucoup mais faut bien commencer
il a beaucoup joué les titles
dernièrement à les raisins il est
peut-être
plus habitué à la cadence
prélestinienne c'est pas forcément la
meilleure ouverture
actuellement
on prend en tout cas il joue vite il
sait ce qu'il fait la pour le moment à
lire les raisins
c'est bien
c'est un bon début
donc ça change d'accord
il va pouvoir ramener ses cavaliers et
ouais c'est qui va essayer de tenir la
case de 4 ans on l'a vu à ce scénario de
partie
dans beaucoup de cas de figure et puis
on B6
permettre du cavalier C5 et de reprendre
de B
petit rock d'accord
je pense qu'il veut faire cavalier c'est
5 maintenant il a joué B6 pour
mais une nouvelle fois les blancs qui
réussissent à visser cette case de 4
donc la case de 4 est VICE c'est le fou
G7 qui réussit pas à jouer
en tout cas ce qui est rassurant là pour
ce début de de segments c'est que c'est
qualifiera joue plus vite ou elle sait
qu'il réussit pas lui à accélérer donc
ça peut peut-être nous créer un quelque
chose d'intéressant
au moins niveau pendule on essaie de
s'accrocher à quelque chose
après faut vraiment qu'il démarre bien
là il peut pas il faut pas qu'il
continue sur sur la lancée de
de leur ennemi de jeu combien de voir à
5 qui stabilise son cavalier il tient la
case B4
je crois qu'il tient la case G4
h6 il tient le pion j'ai 5
les deux joueurs qui bétonnent leurs
avant-postes entre guillemets ou leur
cases
une dame des deux donc
ils améliorent
chacun leur pièce peut-être un coup
comme dame 8 peut être intéressant pour
faire H5
après je sais pas si H5 sera une menace
parce que le pion G5 pourrait être
faible
ou des 7 B3 alors B3 ça peut avoir
l'intérêt de faire tourner un à 3 B4
il va plutôt passer le fou en 8
deux joueurs blinde dans leur position
et les raisins qui passent le cavalier
Descartes alors ça c'est une bonne
opération maintenant le fou avec le coup
F3 se retrouve un peu bloqué
et H5 peut être une menace
H4 c'est pas un coup de base que Wesley
souhaitait jouer
il en a été un petit peu forcé
position compliquée une 18 contre une 10
noir qui ont quand même un pion de plus
qui commence à réussir à taper le
cavalier E4 le cavalier D4 est bien tenu
par le fou
la série de coups précédentes a plutôt
été en
faveur des Noirs clairement
à Roissy qui va peut-être essayer de
faire naviguer une tour le long de la
colonne h à mon avis il va faire tout
rachat
il fait tout romain pour le moment il se
passe en face de la dame adverse ça peut
créer des accidents attention
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le cavalier
a quitté la case des quatre
F2
idéalement je pense qu'il faudrait faire
tout rachat mais c'est long
après les noirs
ont pas mal de cou non plus pour pour
faire l'effort et c'est tout le problème
quand on est derrière au score comme ça
c'est que même si elle est résa
en train de produire une jolie partie
on a on a cette obligation de résultat
quand même on peut plus permettre de
temporiser
à 5 en tout cas c'est bien joué encore
un ça attaque le fou mais ça libère
aussi la case H6
il joue cavalier j'ai 5 le roi qui va
probablement repartir vers G8 38
secondes chacun
c'est un moment important là pour les
supporters
pour revenir dans ce match
prise F5 qui va reprendre de la tour je
suppose
allez il faut jouer
il reprend du fou il prend un H4 je sais
pas il veut peut-être fois 6 pour clouer
il va y avoir F4 après il fait cavalier
3 en premier intéressant ce qui a validé
ça vient désorganiser peut-être un petit
peu les pièces blanches
après il a peut-être dû tout retro 3
fois 6 pour prendre des trois faut
prendre des trois dames prends des trois
fous prends G5 dames G6 dg7 prise G7
prise G5 c'est pour ça qu'il le joue
mais le cavalier qui vient en F4 c'était
vu immédiatement par Ali resa G3
la position est complètement chaotique
ça sent le chaos dans l'air allez gagner
celle là redonne évidemment quand même
confiance
commencez un segment avec une victoire
ça ne peut être que positif alors il y a
peut-être du 5 qui peut atterrir un jour
cavalier aussi
il a peut-être réussi à avoir du faux 5
là Ali
prise d'un point et peut-être il faut 5
il a
est-ce que ça marche c'est dur à dire
il a peut-être fouger 3 mais attention
ça peut se retourner
dommage 7 cavaliers F6 oh là il y a dame
c'est deux regardez l'ordi qui annonce
maintenant 5
il va pouvoir se rapprocher petit à
petit de la tourelle
alors est-ce que c'est vraiment fini
donc j'ai un an à me Pranger trois ouais
ça doit être mat ça
et dame de maths c'est ciao allez une
première victoire pour allier
allez recolle un peu
plus de 4 points d'écart
comme je vous disais ça permet de
recommencer quelque chose de nouveau
en tout cas sur c'est comme si on
reprend une période de jeu là
et qu'on a de l'avance
c'est positif c'est positif
il va prendre F7 pour dame des 5
je crois que ça existe un truc là je
l'ai déjà vu j'ai l'impression
on démarre une autre histoire là
exactement
en espérant que celle-ci soit belle
en espérant que celle-ci soit une belle
histoire
position est très chaotique les noirs
qui ont une tour de plus mais le roi
appelait mal placé le cavalier H1
et pas complètement condamné mais enfin
si on veut vraiment le gagnant on va le
gagner mais il faut quand même aller le
chercher encore c'est pour ça que je dis
pas qu'on condamné
après si regagne ici
ça peut faire mal
ça peut faire très mal
cavalier c'est 6 il va peut-être faire
une mettre une dame en E4 x F5 cavalier
H4 mais dans le 4 c'est un autre
problème ça doit être 3F 7
tout cas Wesley qui est en train de
tanker là
pas forcément ce qu'on voulait
ça réfléchit côté
il fait aussi ce cavaliers F4 évidemment
et 4
non mais là il se met mal au temps mais
il a raison parce qu'en fait la partie
cette partie c'est pas sûr qu'elle dure
beaucoup de cool on est au 12e coup
ça me cas 3 G8 7 dans le 8 en fait on a
l'impression d'être tellement proche
vous allez le voir roi g87 dame 8 seul
coup
cavalier c'est 7 dame 7 prise 7 prises
de 7 prises à 8 OK
variante de fou furieux mais variante
amusante
c'est quoi le matos 1 2 3 4 5 contre 5
pour les pions ouais c'est égalité
matériel
mais j'arrive pas à faire juste
cavaliser cette fois trois rois et deux
tu reprends H1 bon on peut commencer par
faut 3 je pense qu'on a pas de problème
d'ordre de coup
alors l'ordi d'un un truc de fou
c'est qu'en fait quand le fou va être en
D7 le cavalier sera enfermé en C7
waouh ça joue hyper bien
très intéressant
il y avait pas manières il y avait pas
matière à mieux faire en fait
cette partie est quasiment parfaite dans
le jeu vous voyez les évaluation a
toujours rester proche des gars parce
que les joueurs n'ont commis aucune
erreur
je suis assez
admiratif de cette partie là c'est des
parties comme ça qu'on veut voir
c'est des parties comme ça qu'on veut
voir
et là il va remettre le fond en D4
probablement et bouffer en H1 il y a
quand même un pion de plus pour les
blancs
ça peut gagner ça pourra lire ça s'il
est précis alors 24 secondes contre une
19 juste là voilà je trouve que c'est un
moment où il prend trop de temps parce
que
il commence par foub6 mais j'arrive pas
forcément choper ou le fou doit aller en
E3 t'as pas envie parce qu'il y a
cavalier F5 alors après ce que fou B6
fout des cartes ou des quatre direct
ouais mais si c'est peut-être un peu
mieux mais il a quand même investi 20
secondes pour ce coup
faut F5 C3
BK
ca va les dessins 3D 2 et il veut plus
on prend puis on prend et tout racisme
et qui est propre et au racisme
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué
des deux côtés mais ça c'est nettement
mieux pour les blancs alors dit je suis
pas du tout d'accord on va on va faire
avancer tout le schmilblick mettre le
cavalier en D4 c'est si on peut
d'arriver jusqu'en A5 mais je pense
qu'on va se faire bloquer avant
je pense si
peu faire à 4 faites la question là
c'est tout à 5
qui avait les D4 faut prendre G2
et ces quatre j'adore comment il joue là
les raisins
il a donné un pion mais
oh bien joué tourage 5
excellente idée en fait il veut
récupérer H2 filer le fou contre le pion
à 8
et jouer sur son contre jeu
c'est ce qui va faire d'ailleurs
il envoie son pion c'est bien joué
mais le fond à 8 avant de se faire
bloquer
là il menace cavalier prend des 6 quand
même
sur échec pour envoyer un deuxième
collègue
car au lycée
puis tourbé un tourbé 6 cavalier 5 c'est
ça qui veut en fait
toi H3 échec 3D 4 le roi qui monte
je me demande si tu vas pas faire plutôt
cavalier C7 sous ses six touristes
maintenant
faut baisser cette tour B6
x 5 et des 5 il veut tout à 3 encore le
chenapan
c'est pour ça qu'il fait tout racisme
pour empêcher qu'il y ait des cinq il va
mettre la tour en trois maintenant
oh ok il va prendre B7 attendez c'est
pas encore terminé quand même
c'est pas complètement fini
parce que les pions avancent
pour ranger 4 H2 mais à tour H4 et tout
reprend H7 et à qui revient la remontada
est entamée en fait il se faisait juste
chier en 5 + 1 c'est ça le délire
c'était trop long pour lui très très
belle fin de partie
et ouais là tout d'un coup elle iraita
qui qui retrouve la vista tactique
on est d'accord le score c'est bien
cette 4
alors peut-être
il s'était endormi ouais
il était complètement endormi
il fait ses 5
il a vraiment très très bien joué
assez impressionnant ouais
le niveau est assez incroyable
effectivement
le niveau est vraiment impressionnant
ça moindrit plus issu ouais
je sais pas
il est pas mauvais quand même
je veux dire
après c'est sûr que la dynamique du
match en train de changer le match est
encore long
mais là il peut vraiment remonter enfin
c'est certain
Sun domine plus non non là il domine
plus une nouvelle fois on voit que ça se
passe pas mal avec fougères 6 kf5 qui
est des 4 ça arrive
ça arrive
my cavalier 6 une nouvelle fois
la tour qui va arriver en 8 non ça se
passe pas mal
ça ne se passe pas trop mal
mais là c'est le roi blanc en fait qui
peut se retrouver faible allez allez
revenir à deux points
ok il va faire tour à 8
si on gagne une troisième d'affilée il
lui met la tête sous l'eau
là il lui met la tête sous l'eau
mais
ouais c'est cette partie là où il a pas
fait attention il perd ce qui doit
gagner en finance à pièces
ces trucs qui peuvent coûter un moment
donné
sont des erreurs qui peuvent coûter cher
on va voir là la position est quand même
complexe
tout peut arriver il va revenir vers E7
je pense au H6 avec le cavalier
pour taper la case F5
[Musique]
c'est vrai que les pions sur cases
blanches peuvent être faibles par la
suite
c'est bien joué c'est un très bon coup
dame G4 cavalier
[Musique]
il va forcer le changer 4 et peut-être
malin mais bon faut franchise store G3
complexe
on peut remettre la tour en F6 au pire
cavalier F5 etc il a juste à réaliser
quoi je sais pas c'est peut-être le 5 +
1 c'est pas une cadence dans laquelle on
a l'habitude de jouer en fait je sais
même pas pourquoi elle est
pourquoi elle est dedans en fait
ça prend beaucoup de temps et c'est un
peu c'est un peu long pour tout le monde
public compris après c'est pour avoir
quelque chose de très complet peut-être
ça sous la liés raisins comme cadence
mais là en tout cas il regarde il y a
toutes les pièces qui rentrent qui est
mal il va mettre la tour en E2
tu retournes
et là il va aller jouer le matin
regardez
tour B3 cavalier froid il va être obligé
de sacrifier
et perdre la partie
lireza qui va revenir à deux points
ouais il doit pas être bien
il a pas que le roi
mais bon il va quand même gagner la cale
il va gagner la partie avec
et ça va gagner et à lire ça qui revient
à deux points incroyable mesdames et
messieurs on ne s'y attendait absolument
pas le changement de cadence la pose
absolument changer la dynamique du match
contre toute attente
contre toute attente ça on l'avait pas
vu venir mesdames et messieurs
on avait absolument pas venu venir
mais elle est venue
et elle nous met très bien
la petite karaoké
ouais ce sera incroyable
mais ça là enfin moi je m'y attendais
pas du tout en tout cas
je m'y attendais absolument pas
il revient vraiment du Diable Vauvert
je sais pas trop qui est Vauvert mais il
en revient
ça doit être un lieu divin
donc il prend le 5 peut-être à cause de
cavalier prend peut-être fou B5 je sais
pas si j'ai pas n'importe quoi OK
désolé
vos verres c'est un lieu dit non
ou je dis n'importe quoi
ok
c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu à 6
évidemment B5 dans ma CAD d'un dessin
que ça marchait pas
ça veut dire aller se mettre au vert OK
et pourquoi il y avait du diable alors
dans le range
ça la question en fait
en tout cas position complexe d'un côté
il y a le centre c'est la peur de fou
l'évolution des pions à la dame
c'est intéressant ça expression soyez au
château de Vauvert à Gentilly bien
habillé de vos verres maison de
Chartreux rue d'Enfer à Paris
pour les deux premiers lieux origine
diabolique viendrait d'une mauvaise
réputation pour la troisième hypothèse
elle viendrait des représentants
offertes jadis au pèlerin de
Saint-Jacques de Compostelle ou se
jouait
ouais bon c'est pas pourquoi en fait
en tout cas il est pas mal à
je sais pas si les mieux mais il est pas
moins bien ça c'est sûr
c'est en train de s'échanger
il essaye encore de mettre la pression à
l'IRISA il laisse le pion F2 mais pour
attaquer
ses grands rock pour protéger baisses et
mettre le fou sous protection il va
pouvoir surpris F24
ça arrivait probablement vite
ça ça doit être fondamentalement nul en
fait ça va tous échanger le long de la
colonne des je pense
elle dit Ablo
ouais c'est ça c'est exactement ce que
j'étais en train de dire
on peut pas on peut pas y faire
grand-chose en fait
ça c'est complètement nul
ok
il en reste une avant la la pose allez
ne pas perdre
rester sur un sur un bon enchaînement
que tu as les raisins
c'est vraiment là dans le 3 plus 5 le
match est devenu
intéressant si je puis me permettre
5 + 1 tu es vraiment ouais je trouve que
ça casse vraiment le rythme de ces
matchs ça dure ça dure une heure et
demie
c'est une longue mise en route
j'aime bien personnellement voir plus de
3 + 5 et quand même la cadence reine sur
Internet
5 + 5 c'est ouais c'est long on a
tellement l'habitude du 3 + 1 c'est
tellement
surtout que c'est pas ça dure pas deux
minutes avec les pauses et tout tu as
deux heures de 5 + 1
avant d'attaquer le dur et si vous jouez
avec G5 faut que j'ai 7 je pense pas
mais il doit vouloir mettre le fond au 7
et pas se prendre de problème
mais où on est Maxime dans son et ben
écoute il a gagné brillamment son match
hier contre Google
[Musique]
il veut revenir vers ces quatre
ça joue bien là ouais qui est des deux
c'est un joli coup regarde peut-être
s'il peut faire des 5 pour pousser 5 ça
paraît intéressant
des cinq paraître le coup intéressant
pas sûr que ce soit le meilleur si ça
passe
si ça passe c'est fort il fait E5
alors est-ce qu'il veut réussir à
l'enchaîner avec des cinq peut-être
un coup culotté mais qui peut passer
on peut récupérer 4 ouais c'est c'est
complexe là ça se rend compte pourquoi
ça repère des 600 derrière qui joue à me
D8 en fait il veut laisser la dame en C4
qui est mal placé
encore une position très compliquée
près de moi sur à 90% que là je va
sortir famille 99%
c'est plus proche de 99 que de 90
je vois pas trop comment
famille pourrait sortir des griffes
du carreaux mais bon
dure la pause quand même ouais bah là
difficulté c'est ce qui ont des six qui
se retrouve fixés mais bon
et désolé il voulait tout le temps
qu'elle prend le 4
ce que Maxime peut faire tomber le H
forcément c'est très difficile c'est pas
un joueur
qui lui réussit historiquement après
on va espérer que ceux que je te dise
donc
il a peut-être un fou prend C2 après qui
est fort pour dévier la dame
donc il prend E5 plutôt
position une nouvelle fois et très
compliqué
même plus de chance de prendre un Magnus
qui est historiquement maxime a de
meilleurs résultats contre
Magnus exactement
bien joué sous des trois
ouais bah qui a battu ikaro hier au
title exactement il a eu
Guillaume qui est moins dominant dans
l'état actuellement
elle va devoir faire des cinq
ça a été très bien joué la série de quoi
par Wesley
très très bien joué
extrêmement bien joué même
il est obligé de
se débarrasser de ce fou c'était trop
fort
c'est quand même un vrai pion de moins
là pour aller Raisa
se laisse doubler les pions mais pour
pour se réactiver
ouais étonnant quand même c'est pions de
moins et
non la position a l'air dramatique
bizarre de laisser la tour en des deux
on va essayer qui est moins précis
elle a tourné à -2 ce serait vraiment
une bonne opération
ce serait vraiment une très très bonne
opération
il fait un Adam G4 il Adam G5 bien vu
parce que ça tenait la case D1
la Wesley qui suit
qui suit complètement en fait
attention si la dame arrive en D2 après
il y aurait pu avoir la menace de tour
D1
il montre l'oreille il va y avoir du Dam
G4 échec je pense
madame G5 ouais et la finale doit tenir
va reprendre de F mettre la tour en C2
le faire souffrir
alors là si tu veux pas avoir une lettre
du de Tonton cramé qu'il faudrait mieux
que qu'il la tienne
mais oui mais bien la tour en B1 pour
bloquer le roi
il va tenter F4 il doit tenter F4 ouais
c'est il devait le tantôt d'avant
il le temps de pas alors pourquoi il
devait tenter F4 et là ça va être la
pause parce que du coup tour échec on
faisait roi bouger et plus la prise en
passant c'était sa seule chance pour
jouer le gain tonton cramique va
peut-être sortir une vidéo sur Wesley là
pour pas avoir fait F4 attention quand
même
bon sur ce les amis on va prendre la
petite pause et on revient rapidement
très bon match pour le moment de très
bonne très bonne sélection 3 + 1 à
l'IRISA qui semble reprendre le dessus
sur son adversaire en espérant on espère
que ça continue après la pause à tout de
suite vous voulez streamer des échecs
comme vos créateurs préférés tels que
blindstream Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
cheese.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors notre
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/ettings
connectiqueuons mettre échec comme
catégorie sur twitch et commencer à
streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître dans notre
liste de streamers en direct votre
profil affichera votre stream twitch qui
sera aussi mis en avant durant vos
parties offert utiliser la commande
community streamer dans le chat faites
grossir votre audience sans plus
attendre
[Musique]
les amis ça va ça va repartir
en espérant que la pause est pas fait
mal à
qui était très bien reparti après la
pause précédente
et envoie le 4 c'est 5 cavaliers F3
solo
avec G6
il va jouer cavalier C3 je suppose
mais c'est trois et trois d'accord
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
tout était possible
donc là on va sûrement quand même voir
des quatre on prend puis on prend
cavaliers on prend le 5
donc si on prend puis on prend
puis on prend 5 bref c'est complexe
une énième position complexe donc il
nous reste combien de temps dans ce
match pour faire un petit
un petit point
il reste 22 minutes
de 3 + 5 et 30 minutes de belette de
points d'écart c'est serré
dynamique en faveur d'Ali resa il va
falloir
bien négocier cette partie parce que là
les noirs sont
très bien sortis de l'ouverture
ils sont vraiment très bien sortis de
l'ouverture ici les noirs
donc il va falloir
redoubler d'ingéniosité pour pour pas
s'incliner
d'entrée
c'est vrai que en ayant cette énorme
tapis de 5 points au début du
Blitz
il force quand même
à ne pas avoir de baisse de régime
il va probablement aller en H4 avec le
fou pour
repasser vers G3 j'imagine
non il prend H6 et dessin OK
une sortie B4 il a pas d'âme des 4 sur
les cavaliers C2
attention on n'a jamais de Tours
s des deux faut se développer et menacé
peut-être d'aller jusqu'en D6
mais en belette sur la
dynamique du match j'ai l'impression que
ce serait plutôt à lire et ça qui serait
favori personnellement
en tout cas pour moi sur la dynamique de
ce que l'on voit
j'imaginerai plutôt à l'IRESA favoris
après
c'est pas du 1 + 0 c'est du 1 + 1
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
mais surtout que soit une baisse de
régime mais c'est pas dit qu'elle
continue
tout ça pour dire que c'est loin d'être
certain qui est
une grosse différence
à les raisins doit être un peu plus fort
mais
ça va pas forcément être un carnage quoi
par contre
car il y a trois Dali resa était
peut-être un peu optimiste
peut-être même très optimiste
en plus super bien placées côté blanc
c'est complexe
il y avait des découvertes
malheureusement
type cavalier prend le 5
pour ça qu'il a pas pu le faire marcher
mais là il se met tellement mal au temps
il retombe un peu dans ses travers
du début de match
il retourne un peu dans ses travers de
début de match
ça semble trop court pour
pour réussir à tenir
dommage
d'un B3 allez alors peut-être et là il
faut penser 6 et qui va aller prendre 5
il a raté une pièce
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
il a raté la pièce on sait qu'il y avait
encore gaffé
comme ça c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
ça veut quand même dire que Wesley quand
il y a peu de temps il est il est
fragile
il va échanger roi je sais loin d'être
perdu ah j'ai trois ça ouvre trop
allez faut revenir plus de 2 secondes 2
ça suit quand même côté Wesley pour
conclure
il a peur des cavaliers F6 qui
reviennent
fait vraiment mal maintenant avec le
clouage
il met la dame en E2
il va devoir lâcher une pièce allez faut
peut-être encore un peu la jouer il y a
peu de temps il y a du dame C3 échec qui
rôde
allez il essaye maintenant de rentrer en
H6 et cavaliers
oh ça c'est pas de bol
ça c'est pas de bol pour Wesley oh il a
pas eu de bol ah il a pas eu de bol
ouais
c'est pas de bol
ouais donc vous avez un début de réponse
sur sur le bolet
ah ouais il a pas eu de bol là ouais
c'est le coup hasard
qui est pas passé il y a plus qu'un
point d'écart ouais c'est qui est en
train de se faire
dominer Wesley sodominés ici en 3 + 1 ça
fait déjà 5 ans
ah ouais alors qu'il avait fait un début
de match tonitruant
mais là il est en train d'exploser
il est en train de complètement imploser
j'ai jamais vu une telle remontada en
speechs
il aurait pu mener de
c'était même mal payé en fait le l'écart
de points
allez attention de pas se griser là à
côté côté
ça lâche rien ouais
faut pas lâcher de point bêtement
attention
et oui tu habites qui nous dit quelque
chose de vrai dans le château soit plus
long pour être bien sûr alors
on prend ton
questionnant parce que c'est vrai quand
on va des matchs qui peuvent se
retourner comme ça on a même de ce de se
demander vu qu'il y aura moins de partie
en 5 + 1 si j'avais pas fallu que le 5
plus 5 soit un peu plus long
c'est une question complètement légitime
de
tu habites
questionnement légitime
ah par contre la partie peut-être un peu
à côté
heureusement que la partie d'avant a
tourné parce que ça pourrait
position kata je suis pas trop ça mal
tourné dans l'ouverture mais la lapine
qui a fait mal
c'est pas une position qui donne envie
d'être jouer
pas de variante précise mais pour un
pion de moins et le roi est dégueu
terrible
pas trop tous les coups là franchement
petite déconcentration de ma part
et c'est long pour tout le monde on a ça
fait déjà
trois heures au final
majeur de vivre presque trois heures
mais avec la prépa du stream et tout ça
fait
trois heures qu'on est là concentré
et au bout d'un moment c'est dur pour
les organismes
bizarre cette position
à deux doigts d'être mal mais ils
tiennent
et sur A5 il veut cavaler des 5 dame C4
F5
ça va être joué tempo j'espère
je leur dis donc cavalier à 8 en main
mais bon
il a fait ça comme ça
c'est pas bête qui fait
c'est ingénieux G5 croisé 6 pour
enfermer le foie H6
case
assez ouf l'ordi d'un égal parce que
surtout référent
il a pas trouvé quand même le meilleur
coup j'ai envie de dire heureusement
pour Wesley ça commence à faire trop
la position
chaotique il y a pièce de plus mais
c'est mieux pour les blancs parce que le
pion à 7 il a une énorme valeur
on voit les noirs qui ont du mal à
s'organiser en défense
on est faible allez il envoie le pion
des deux secondes 4 quand même et ce qui
peut encore la voler
est-ce qu'on a le droit à une nouvelle
escroquerie qui a le droit il y a une
chanson comme ça qui a le droit
t'en prends des oeufs à me prendre des
deux prises F6 3g8 dame G5 roh H8 il y a
pas de maths et là c'est tout ou non
qui gagnait
quel dommage
retour un échec c'était le coup le plus
facile en plus
et c'est le coup qui gagnait
la vie
alors cette finale elle donne quoi
elle est
est peut-être juste nulle par répétition
de coup incroyable
les noirs qui pouvaient pas la gagner
les pions aller avancer et donc on se
quitte sur une drôle
mais il est même repassé par gagnant un
moment donné c'est incroyable
ah ouais c'est les qui réussit pas à
maîtriser le feu tactique du joueur
français
ah il s'est mis mal au temps une
nouvelle fois il a réussi à s'en sortir
c'est de mauvaise augure pour Wesley en
belette maintenant peut-être que Wesley
c'est d'en gagner une ou deux là pour se
refaire un petit matelas
je pense pas qu'il y arrive Wesley a
gagné le match si il a pas plus d'avance
la jeunesse est un atout vu le marathon
ne dit Tortue Géniale non on nous dit
quelqu'un d'autre dans le chat
si c'est Tortue Génial qui me dit ça
voilà bon c'est pas
c'est du clic après
c'est comme ça
ok des deux
attention pas de fou ici sur des 5 mais
ça c'est des petits trucs
peuvent arriver à votre niveau
il se décide à faire des 5 C4 B4 c'est 5
allez faut pousser comme des fous
OK
pour commencer
mieux jouer
moins peut-être interdire B6
ça a l'air plus malin
la position est vraiment complexe
il y a vraiment interdit baisser avec sa
carte à 5
complexe très complexe
B1 ici c'est joli pour éviter F5 et se
placer en face du roi
c'est encore être une partie importante
là toutes les parties vont être
importantes
ce qu'il a mis des lentilles
F2 surtout pour éviter F4
qui était la menace
parce qu'on fait ces quatre pour ces 5
ou est-ce qu'on donne le fond à 600
premiers paraît logique de se
débarrasser du fou quand même je trouve
ça semble être une décision normale
et maintenant à savoir si les noirs
peuvent mater ou pas en fait
la question c'est de savoir si l'attaque
des noirs est suffisant ou pas
et 2 il pourra peut-être repartir avec
le roi en E2
qui fait 5
force un peu la prise en passant
et ces signes
il prend HK d'abord et c'est 5
maintenant et si la dame H4 sert à rien
ça va tourner pour les blancs
ça peut bien se passer encore une fois
pour aller Raisa qui peut à égaliser là
à une partie de la fin du Bullet du du 3
+ 1 et avant le bolet incroyable se
retournement
c'est du jamais vu
c'était d'en prendre des 6 cavaliers
c'est 4
il fait dame c'est 3 il prépare cavalier
C4 il est en train de l'écraser de les
crabouiller
quelle partie de fou une nouvelle fois à
les raisins là qui
se montre très à droite très agile avec
ses pièces voilà il va mettre la tour en
D1 et il va rentrer
mais si c'est tellement bien joué aussi
cavalier propion prend et cavalier C5 ça
rentre de partout ouais c'est qui se
fait écraser et c'est égalité mesdames
et messieurs comment c'est juste
possible quali Raisa soit revenu il
avait cinq points de retard
et il vient d'enchaîner les victoires
ça doit suer extrêmement fort côté côté
américain
donc un nouveau match commence ouais ça
va jouer sur le Bullet allez c'est la
dernière en 3 plus simple
mettre un punto de plus ça va pas
ça nous dérangerait pas de partir
carrément avec de l'avance
il a le momentum donc ouais il faut en
fait si la paire il perd pas
complètement le même temps parce qu'il
sera revenu de 4 points mais quand même
ça remet du baume au coeur à Wesley là
c'est partir à la pause en faisant au
moins nul avec les Noirs voire même
gagner ce serait
extrêmement positif
on va voir
ce qu'il arrive à faire on ne pas faire
en tout cas le retournement de situation
et
très inattendue maintenant impression
que c'est Wesley qui note des trucs
pas trop c'est pas lui qui est pas en
train de faire son shopping
en tout cas une victoire derrière ici
pour remettre un sacré coup de bambou
sur la tête de Wesley
ça là elle peut faire très très mal
Salah elle peut faire très très mal
ouais
il va tout lui envoyer dessus ouais
c'est terrible là pour pour
c'est
5 il veut cavaler des trois là elle est
dure
ça fait mal
qui va être le fond en H6
il va venir taper sur sur les cases
c'est fou comment ça ça suit
comment ce match a complètement changé
de dynamique
la Tour Eiffel t'aurait fuite maintenant
un plan que Ali résa souvent employé
les échecs ça se joue sur sur des
détails
il fait si il veut vraiment interdire
les C5
à tout prix
c'est bien joué
B3 ça consolide aussi
à 5 mais bon cette consolidation elle
est vraiment en faveur
des Noirs en fait parce qu'il bloque
toutes les cases
je crois qu'il y avait vraiment
qui prend le 4 x 4
ça va être un peu mieux pour pour Ali
c'est lui qui a le contrôle d'accord
cavalage 5 qui est le coup le plus le
plus gourmand
il va peut-être commencer à doubler
maintenant
parce que Tour Eiffel 3 il y aura pas de
il y aura plus de prise et j'ai trois
pièges j'ai trois dames G3 qui est G3
dames G3
mais bon
peut-être dame prend le cas ouais sur
Tour Eiffel
peut-être dans l'autre sens
mais en tout cas ça a pas l'air de bien
se passer pour
pour Wesley celle-là
peut-être quand même il veut garder le
fou mais bon il doit bien passer un
moment donné par l'échange
pour taper sur sur G3
et là il y a égalité un cercle qui peut
même tourner avec l'avantage incroyable
MG4 bien joué pour essayer de
même pas pour essayer mais pour échanger
les dames
ça va toujours sur le bolet
cavalier F2
H6
ah c'est pas clair cavalier F2 roi j'ai
un forfait tourbouge et qui va les
prendre G4 au prochain
ah c'est complexe
ah mais tour à 8 il y a tout retroit et
cavalier G4
très bien joué ça de la part des blancs
ça donner l'avancée ouais et là il fait
cavalier j'ai quatre sur G3 il y a ton
G6 en G4 H6
mais qu'est-ce que c'est fort
des deux côtés
ah ouais c'est maintenant qui réfléchit
il tente tu aurais fait ouais ça c'était
la ligne que j'avais aussi
il va probablement je vais tout
reprendre j'ai 5 ici
bref j'ai 7 Tours FC
tournage 5 est-ce qu'il va faire rager 6
pour F5 il va caler un tour 7 ou pas
il fait tourrer fuite il coupe le roi il
avait plus roi F5
et ouais c'est qui qui prend la nul et
ben écoutez mesdames et messieurs
on va revenir après la pause avec une
aiguille égalité parfaite avant les
belettes et de joueurs ont remporté
chacun la section 5 puissant ou trois
plus un sur le corps le score de 7 2 et
on va voir
en belette c'est à les raisins réussi à
terminer le travail parce qu'il semble
être favori mais on verra bien ça dans
une petite dizaine de minutes à tout de
suite les amis
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier sur
plat du monde au tournoi des candidats
en passant par le speechestre ou les
titles.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec qui se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne visbez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats des
comptes rendus quotidien les dures des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition aux pronostiquant les
résultats tentez de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur James consommes cash
revanche aussi bien sur le site internet
sur nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors les amis ça va bientôt repartir je
vais arrêter de mettre les
scores à jour parce que j'aurais pas le
temps donc si vous voulez voir le score
il faut regarder en dessous de
l'échiquier je pense que ça suffit
amplement et ce sera à laisser le score
total tout à droite je préfère le dire
parce que
on sait jamais donc ça va reprendre un
là avec avec Ali resa qui semble favori
sur la dynamique du match en tout cas
maintenant le Bullet qui va reprendre
dans 35 secondes il peut avoir sa propre
vérité c'est du 1+1 c'est pas dû en plus
zéro
donc c'est pas c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose
c'est pas les mêmes coûts pas la même
dynamique
c'est un jeu un petit peu un petit peu
différent
donc on va voir dans 20 secondes à un
début reprise dans 20 secondes
allez prendre la tout de suite
l'avantage continuer sur la dynamique
s'il gagne les deux trois premières à
lire et ça fait un break de deux trois
parties je pense que ce sera fini des
espoirs de Wesley on se dirigera vers
une demi-finale de gala contre Magnus
Carlsen peut-être
il va falloir mettre les puntos ici et
commencer par mettre le Punto allez ça y
a l'IRESA qui commence avec les Blancs
il envoie le Punto en E4 Wesley qui
décide de partir sur la carrocane c'est
la variante d'avance c'est 5 direct 3
cavaliers C6 puis on prend C5 fougait 4
c'est 3 on l'a déjà vu ça dans le match
il va y avoir le fou 3 cavalier 7 il
avait joué fou des trois je crois ici il
fait fou B5 cette fois-ci à 6 qui arrive
quand même et ce qui va décaler le fond
à 4 oui c'est le cas x 4 jouer ouais
c'est les sauts qui prend son temps qui
réfléchit on voit les raisins qui
réussit à tout jouer tempo pour le
moment et là il y a peut-être fou
français 6 d'ArmA 4 fois F3 dames C6 et
puis on prend F3 trouver immédiatement
par Ali resa qui vient mettre son
adversaire au supplice alors il peut
carrément commencer par fe se garder les
deux options et c'est fait et ça va déjà
faire un pion plus pour aller Raisa dès
le dès le début voire même deux puis en
plus en réalité
voire même deux pions plus c'est ce qui
va caler un âme des six échecs non il le
fait pas il y a pas de raison de le
faire et là sur Dame des 6 il veut roi
huit dame prend des huit trois prend des
8 B4 ouais ça a l'air très puissant
quand même côté blanc ça a l'air d'être
deux pions de plus clean de chez clean
ici
alors on va tenter encore côté Wesley de
jouer par G5
car il est de fouger 7 F4
ouais ça paraît ça paraît compromis là
pour Monsieur saut
il a la tête dedans
froid trop il tient il tient tous les
pions
il tient tous les pions
il veut encore tout refait un tour G8
allez c'est pas fait encore bizarrement
de Tanger
il va peut-être faire F6 puis on prend
et E5
ah c'est pas idiot là ce que fait Wesley
je vous les coups directs mais il veut
il veut il veut y arriver
il joue avec F6
peut-être 3D 3 maintenant on laisse le
pion F4 finalement
mais ouais qui sentir et qui est mieux
autant maintenant alors il y a toujours
un pion de plus pour aller Raisa il y a
toujours avantage pour les blancs
mais on a ces deux pions passés liés et
on a les pièces là qui sont en train de
naviguer pour pour les Noirs la tour qui
arrive en G2 le pion H2 qui tombe le fou
qui pourra peut-être repasser viager un
alors il vient en E3 directement il va
quand même pouvoir aller passer en géant
je sais pas pourquoi il a réfléchi sur
ton projet de
il réfléchissait peut-être au coup
d'après
oui s'il prend H2 le pion B peuvent
filer donc il envoie le pion des
le pion c'est qui file
ça file ça file de tous les côtés
est-ce que les noirs peuvent s'en sortir
peut-être f63c7 il va peut-être y avoir
à cavalier c'est 5 ici et fort
et il y a du à cinco maintenant et c'est
cette C8 et ouais c'est là qu'on a vu la
la différence et tourbé 6 sur B8 ah
c'est trop
ah c'est trop
tomber si ce soir V8 qui fait trop mal
ah il hésite peut-être il fait cavalier
B7 alors là désolé j'ai pas
il a peut-être peur
de la contre-attaque
qui arrivait très fort à la
contre-attaque oh là bien joué cavalier
C4 on C4 il y a C8 dames
mais ça va être joué il va recacher son
rond en B3 pourquoi est-ce qu'il fait ça
n'a pas trop compris la petite passe
d'armes attention de pas se faire ma
tête c'est pas si clair encore
ah il arrive
pas à menacer de maths heureusement
pour ces deux rois D1 tour des deux rois
et deux tours 2
non il va repartir de l'autre côté oh la
partie est complètement folle
ah ça fait quand même un peu peur
roi B3 il va est-ce qu'il peut prendre à
6 en fait c'est ça que je me demande
il peut pas il pouvait pas vraiment
suivant le tempo
pas se faire mater ah il laisse le pion
arrivé en D2 oh il y a du bermax non il
aura ah mais ça continue à le menacer
oh c'est trop oh c'est trop ira de ma
tendre et là il y a dames et de dames C3
il s'est gagné oh là là là là
oh c'est trop oh il avait raté ma
tendance oh c'est beaucoup trop c'est
beaucoup trop et ça fait ça fait 10 à 8
là
oh cette fin de partie heureusement que
le dame B5 continue à menacer dame
bermatt complètement par hasard
oh ça a été clique complètement hasard
et on retourne sur une ouverture qu'on a
déjà eu
il s'en est passé des choses il faudra
mieux jouer pour les deux hommes contre
Caro hein quand même je préfère vous le
dire tout de suite contre le H tout ça
c'est un peu léger
en tout cas il y a ça qui a l'avantage
au temps et c'est déjà une bonne chose
pour ce début de partie
allez il reste il reste plus que 25
minutes de jeu ça fait quand même
beaucoup de parties en peu latin mais
bon on est devant car il revient en G7
il va repartir en F5
et surtout ranger 7 rapprocher 7 cahier
des 5 il y avait du temps à me prendre
des cinq
donc ça va là on imagine cavalier F5
faubourg des 4 mais bon ça donne un peu
les cases quand même
ah c'est compliqué
il y a des arguments
à faire valoir de chaque côté c'est case
noir affaiblies mais bon d'un autre côté
des quatre cavaliers 4 fois 6 fous des 5
c'est avantage ici
peut-être cavalier B4 maintenant puis
cavalier 3
enfin avantage blanc personnellement
quand même mais non c'est pas c'est pas
le cas
ça reste compliqué
ça va vite
j'ai peur qu'à un moment donné du BK
qui tient malgré le petit retard au
temps c'est vrai que le cavalier peut
aller en E3 quand même
donne un pion mais ça permet aux pièces
de respirer je pense qu'il va faire
qu'elle va lui au 3 ici ça récupère B2
derrière il y a peut-être des cavaliers
5 qui peuvent exister puis on prend un
point F3 maintenant il va faire tout ras
des 8 pour commencer
pour pas perdre des cartes en fin de
ligne
un 4 c'est bien joué aussi
il faut prendre trois prises de trois
prises 3 ça parait risqué quand même
pour les blancs
ça doit aller mais en belette toujours
dangereux d'avoir le roi un peu ouvert
comme ça
je préfère les noirs
je préfère les Noirs parce qu'il y a
trop de trop de fourchettes trop de
trucs à regarder même un coup comme
cavalier F5 il paye pas de mine voilà il
y a peut-être des
il y a énormément de coups qui payent
pas de mine
et qui sont pas mauvais voilà ça va
faire nul il va prendre la drogue Wesley
fuite ça ça fait aucun intérêt et ouais
c'est qui prend la nul mais c'est plutôt
en faveur d'aller resa tout ça
c'est nous maintenant qui sommes devant
dans le match
en plus avec les pièces noires
c'est pas mauvais allez petite française
sur eu l'impression que c'est une
ouverture très difficile à jouer en
belette parce que il y a ce manque
d'espace
qu'on peut avoir beaucoup d'attaques
avec avec les Blancs
après
des spécialistes de l'ouverture
se sentent à l'aise on va voir si Wesley
fait partie des spécialistes telles Fab
des deux il se prémunit des éventuels
clouages qui arrivent en B4
il veut jouer maintenant avec A4 mettre
le cavalier peut-être en B5 il va
peut-être dû à 5 et il prend à 5
cavaliers à 4
cavalier prend je sais pas ok il prend
des cinq vêtements plus simple mais il
va aller enfoncer le pion à 6 maintenant
à les raisins
il a colonne C va être sensible le pion
le pion a aussi
dans ma carte là va arriver
car il est Caroline qui peut
éventuellement atterrir en B5 le petit
rock la tour en C1 cavalue en B5
c'est intéressant parce que c'est
interdit un peu cavalier 7
c'est interdit aussi le déplacement du
cavalier toujours il y a cavalier c'est
alors et ce qui menace quelque chose à
base de caille prend le 5 à toute façon
qu'elle va laisser 7 échec intermédiaire
et ouais c'est là qui est en train de
boire du calice jusqu'à la lie
la Tour Eiffel là ça rentre de partout
menace tu reprends ces 6 tom prend ses 6
cavalier des 6 cavaliers prend B7 c'est
terminé mais moi je l'avais vu
les cavaliers des 6 mais moi j'avais
Nicolas
ouais c'est dur c'est dur pour Wesley là
qui se fait
tout simplement écraser
et là il le sent
là c'est l'équivalent d'une semelle de
chaussures sur la gueule là qu'il est en
train de se prendre Wesley sceaux et
chicanement parlant là c'est la semaine
qui est en train de l'écraser faire
attention qui reste pas avec une trace
sur la joue heureusement que ce ne sont
que des échecs
parce que sinon ça ferait mal
mais ouais là il vient il vient
d'enchaîner il était à plus 5 il a - 2
ça veut dire qu'il vient de se prendre
moins 7 dans la tronche il vient de se
prendre un œuf et demi à deux et demi
avant le chanteur qui nous écrit dans le
chat celed ouais
bah ouais là il est en train de se faire
écrabouiller
je vais me permettre c'est un petit peu
comme comme dans la rue on marche comme
ça on peut on peut glisser il faut quand
même faire attention que tu as les
raisins de pas s'en percher
s'il continue à appuyer comme ça
ça peut ça peut faire mal dans ce mail
il y a ça exactement
et il a le seum là Wesley
qui fait F5
il va envoyer du F4 peut-être un ami
veut il veut se faire fermer attention
quand même
les colonnes se ferment
il fait cavalier c'est 7 là c'est
peut-être une position pour pour Wesley
il faut qu'il revienne
combien de temps reste-t-il il reste 19
minutes à jouer
allez il a bloqué le fou quand même hein
donc les Noirs vont forcément prendre je
pense en 4
parce qu'il a besoin un jour de jouer au
4 lui-même
il veut F4 et dame prend j'ai ça ouais
qu'est-ce qu'il est fort là il va faire
F4 dame prend G5 af4 prendre à me
Pranger 5 il a le temps de décaler le
roi
et là c'est une décision cornélienne
Corneille
SKF 4 français 5 qui est français 5 rois
bouge le Fou est enfermé à vitam eternam
il a pris un peu trop de temps pour pour
prendre la décision
elle est dur à jouer la position il a un
problème
à très long terme dans la position côté
noir
ça c'est hyper pénible à jouer
bah il a pas le temps de prendre
il a ce fou qui est complètement enterré
et dommage je crois il veut tout rage 2
en bêtement
il arrive pas à le gagner ce pion G5
et tant que le pion G5 reste en vie le
fois chute ne joue pas un regardé c'est
rare ça comme cas de figure
et Jul littéralement avec une pièce de
moins
c'est égalité matérielle mais le X8 ne
peut plus rentrer en jeu
alors il essaye de taper sur un damage 3
allez il essaye de tourner côté
un peu à gauche un peu à droite
la dame maintenant qui touche en plus la
case de 7 c'est pas agréable pour ça
qu'il remet le cavalier en E6 il va le
remettre en D4 là il temporise en fait
il fait des allers-retours
rapide
pour s'acheter du temps
voilà il va revenir en D4 de toute façon
et il va essayer peut-être un moment
donné d'avoir un tour en C4 qui prend F3
il veut tout reprendre ici c'est
évidemment il va le faire bien jouer et
tu reprends B6 quand même
allez faut aller chercher du taf avec la
dame oh il y a réussi à prendre G5 il va
ça il se libère le fou mais ouais c'est
trop tard
la qualité de plus fait mal elle est
fort amener le rendu si vite
à bien jouer encore de la part de Wesley
là
oh il y a pas de 5 à fout des 6 oh c'est
pas de bol il va faire [__]
oh
qui est très bien joué roi G8 en basque
et fou prend H6 maintenant qu'est-ce que
c'était beau ou trois
fois bien joué aussi là le petit
chichake
ouais ça joue très très fort des deux
côtés
mais normalement le le les pions passés
liés là font trop mal
le prince là qui peut pas il faut qu'il
envoie le pion h
il faut qu'il mette le fond en E7
ah il a pas de coup en fait
c'est ignoble
il y a pas de coup
il n'y a pas de coup
trop dur
c'est trop dur ouais
très très belle partie
allez le 4 5 ça repart plus 15 minutes
de jeu plus simple pour
pour le prince qui va rejouer son
italien sans ces trois peut-être non il
le fait cette fois-ci et on va voir le
droit à cette poussée de pions
désagréable
allez le roi alors on avait une partie
avec le pion A4 mais qui est permis
d'une dame B3 parce qu'il y avait pas de
cavalier à 5 on va voir si elle est résa
revient sur sur ces traces ou pas
G4
D3 peut-être qui va arriver
un moment donné pas encore 50 secondes
contre 55 ouais c'est qui est un petit
peu accéléré
ce point de retard
qui pourrait être suffisant déjà à lire
résa avait fait un mauvais départ
mauvais début de match contre
de revenir graduellement
5 + 5 sont vraiment pas lu convenir et
ça s'est terminé
à un point d'écart un contre-andre
équine on va voir s'il réussi à
gagner une deuxième fois par la plus
petite des marges
il va y avoir dame 8 ici
le coup évident mais 8 B5 et il y aura
pas cavalier 7 à cause de caille prend
le 5 peut-être ça peut être une idée si
la dame perd la connexion il y aurait le
Cavaillon H5 qui pose problème en tout
cas ouais c'est vient de jeter pas mal
de temps à la pendule pour pour jouer
cavalier F6
ouais
c'est pas ce qu'il veut c'est ce qu'il
veut pour des 4 alors
26 secondes contre 32
pour reprendre deux points d'avance et
refaire un mini break dans ce match
allez ça réfléchit côté ouais c'est vrai
ça va ça qui en G5 ça va ça qui en G5
allez F quoi trop
allez il faut tout envoyer là il faut
envoyer la purée
si on peut parler de purée
c'est logique ce F4 là pour pour tout
ouvrir
il donne la cale allez on protège le
pion et après on y va en force là on
envoie le 15 de France
allez le Petit Age Quattro
on se consolide tout prise en E5
pourquoi pas et cavalier F3 et c'est
aussi très logique
allez on prend aussi s'il va reprendre
de la dame et peut-être dame dessin car
on prend E5
prix C4 qui revient j'ai 6 cavalue 5 qui
menace la fourchette
rien
des deux
ça donne envie mais ça termine peut-être
pas
des 5 tours 8 attaque ce cavalier
qui jaillit et au sein quoi la position
est complexe on arrive même plus à
savoir qui est mieux matériellement
c'est solide des deux côtés
ça prend B7 ça prend à trois qui
menacent quoi j'en sais rien en tout cas
les Blancs ont l'air d'être plus proche
du roi adverse
le cavalier qui a fait un aller-retour
j'ai cinco la tour qui revient en F3 le
pion qui file en A5 en A3 je sais pas si
menace j'ai 5 en tout cas il y a plus de
temps là deux secondes chacun relève 4
qui fait peut-être mal et à Tours F7 oh
ça fait mal là il a réussi à jouer très
très vite
Wesley mais il y a peut-être la tour qui
vient à 4 maintenant
c'est 5G 2 est-ce que le Roi peut aider
est-ce que le pion qui est mieux
j'ai envie de dire les blancs mais il y
a quand même le pion là qui tombe ah le
roi qui revient en C4 il va faire du
bien lui
mais attention le cavalier va revenir
vers B6
j'ai pas trop il va avec son son cheval
où vas-tu comme ça tout seul dans le
noir
il essaie de se réorganiser
bien joué B6
il veut pas échanger pour gagner des
garder des chances de gains il veut
gagner ici et maintenant Wesley
attention il va le choper le pion B6
il va mettre le cavalier en 17 attention
il est en train de fermer toutes les
portes là Wesley
puertas
le cavalier qui est en train de danser à
gauche à droite
allez c'est bien ça de la part de
setup auquel je m'attendais avec avec
les noirs et maintenant il va essayer de
faire revivre le cavalier vers la case
des quatre
c'est une leçon de manœuvre là allez
reviens reviens à lui
mais le cavagnon a5 il va essayer
d'accompagner avec le roi maintenant
il y a un genre de zouk Zang
et qui vit en B3 qui vit en D2 et
maintenant qui contrôle toutes les cases
le roi qui chasse le la tour de la
quatrième rangée le pion C4 qui tombe
maintenant et à qui revient à égalité au
prix d'un jeu de manœuvre exceptionnel
c'est 11,5
dans cette finale qui est de Wesley
pardon dans cette finale qui a réussi à
danser avec son cavalier sur toutes les
cases la salsa avec le roi
l'égalité est parfaite entre les deux
hommes
à l'IRESA
qui a un petit coup de petit coup de
moins bien là il vient d'en perdre deux
il faut tout de suite tout de suite tout
de suite en remettre une il reste 10
minutes il reste encore quatre parties
peut-être c'est le bon état
je suis
il se décale allez peut-être 4 ah il
veut probablement pas jouer au 4 il veut
pas ouvrir
ce fout du Londres donc il envoie G5
peut-être pour G4 peut-être pour F4
allez ne pas se mettre mal au temps
restez au contact c'est bien ce qui fait
là cavalier 7
le roi yokai qui va revenir vers G6 on
va essayer d'aller attaquer le roi
adverse
c'est bien dame 7 allez on blindon
blindon blanc les barbeles
chacun
a pas vraiment de menace à proprement
parler il décide de faire le 4 pour
peut-être jaillir vers des trois avec le
cheval attention ce fou maintenant est
grand ouvert
attention il y a des cases là pour les
blancs
il y a des cases là
c'est toujours pénible dans ce Londres
là à ce fois deux
dans ce monde il est justement tapis pas
dans l'ombre mais dans l'ombre
et à lireza qui est en train de tanquer
20 secondes pour un coup en belette
c'est beaucoup
mais c'est peut-être un bon coup allez
F3 il faut il faut y aller il faut
rentrer il prépare froid il va falloir
l'envoyer ce F3
alors attention c'est le bordel
allezza qui s'active là c'est bien c'est
bien c'est bien il a trouvé des
solutions assez problèmes il a réussi à
réenfermer ce fou
dans un tombeau ne ressort pas surtout
pas on va t'enfermer mais lui une
cagoule devant la thetas
cavalier il veut chasser le cavalier il
veut faire respirer ce fou
allez j'ai cinq sais jouer et lui met la
cagoule là
il prend le Punto quand même en C7
ah c'est dur là c'est dur à lire autant
il peut y avoir des maths du couloir le
foie je dois être mal placé
il va garder la tour il va la garder non
il les change roi et fin il y a fou fou
des trois qui gagnent
oh il a tort qui va arriver en D2 il a
pas l'air bien la Wesley
allez il faut il faut la gagner ça là il
faut la gagner
G4 allez on rentre on pénètre allez le
fond E4 allez le tour en E2 le fond en
F3 elle est pour toi Ali resa ouais
foutait trois bien joué oh il blinde
encore avec crois géant ah si ce fou peu
atterrir sur la diagonale ce sera gagné
oh 4
fait mal
peut-être prendre la nul peut-être
prendre la nulle côté noir
ouais
j'ai deux rois je crois peut-être qui
était très intéressant pour lui mais il
paye ça peut tritudes et on reste à
égalité parfaite 7 minutes à jouer c'est
12 partout mesdames et messieurs
allez ça retourne dans cette Italienne
elle était pas si mal au blanc celle-là
tout à l'heure elle nous a échappé mais
pour un rien
allez envoie-lui des cadres fais-lui mal
il veut demande que ça
j'ai quatre
H3 le fou qui revient en 17 c'est du
connu c'est du vue est revue il a voulu
provoquer le H3 pour nous envoyer les
pions dans la tronche oh là là là là
attention celle-là elle peut elle peut
faire mal un grand rock H5 G4 il va
falloir que que West envoie et il envoie
le joueur américain qui va tout donner
dans cette partie il a décidé d'aller la
gagner celle-là lui qui a la réputation
d'être l'autre mais qu'il a ouvre le jeu
comme jamais
il veut il veut faire souffrir
notre fer de lance français
allez-vous cinq
c'est en train de rentrer avec du HK G4
là quand même attention faut peut-être
faire H4 nous-mêmes
quoi je sais pas ce que ça vaut mais
plus de 33 secondes contre 47 là-haut ça
peut coûter cher ouais elle peut coûter
très très cher cette attaque
il hésite à envoyer il a fait H4 il veut
fermer la porte
prise faut prendre
et j'ai trois ouais il veut il veut Il
veut
verrouiller la case oh il veut rentrer
en H3 maintenant
peut-être te repranger cinq dates 3
cavaliers G4 H4 il y a peut-être tout
qui rentre plus 17 secondes allez ça
dans le doute là
il va falloir sortir une défense de
géant email cavalier en G1 il tient la
case il va falloir remettre l'autre
Cavaillon F3 et peut-être un jour un fou
c'est 4 là pour aller me chasser ça
c'est en train d'arriver c'est en train
d'arriver de partout ça me set dame j'ai
trois on tient encore
j'ai trois c'est seul coup on n'a pas
envie de la mettre ici la dame
j'ai 8 cavalier F3 on va tenter quelque
chose comme ça à Mia cavalier prend F2
qui gêne faut jouer vite en tout cas
oh
ça s'appelle une dame
prend H4 en plus on boit le calice
jusqu'à la lit
et ouais c'est ça qui reprend l'avantage
quand on le pensait perdu Wesley il
avait
deux points de retard le break était
fait côté français à l'IRISA qui est un
peu levé le pied qui lui était à 200%
depuis plus de deux heures ils cravacher
pour récupérer son début de match
complètement raté
terminé à décider d'en remettre une
couche c'est un point de retard et il
reste deux parties mesdames et messieurs
plus que deux parties plus que deux
balles dans le chargeur de Dali resa il
va falloir toucher la cible
il part pour pour l'instant Diane de
cavalier qui revient en 17 qui va
revenir vers E5 qui va aller toucher la
case des trois c'est solide quand même
pour les blancs c'est une balle de match
pour Wesley Sow évidemment ouais là avec
avec le temps qui reste ouais celle-là
elle va elle va déjà durer elle va déjà
durer deux trois minutes donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment il en reste
vraiment que deux
perdre éliminerait à lire les arts ce
serait incroyable que qui viennent
perdre cette séquence de belette il y a
pas de foutrant H3 il faut prendre H3
cavalier F3 pour le moment c'est tenu 40
secondes chacun la pression doit être à
son comble les battements de cœur
doivent être élevés là chez les deux
joueurs à 4 c'est bien sur B4 c'est
qu'il y ait des trois qui est prend B4
il prend l'avantage autant à lire et ça
alors peut-être un blitz
allez cavaliers des trois il faut
rentrer dans les trous c'est fait 20 10
secondes d'avance c'est lui qui a le la
vista tactique allez prendre une fois en
B3 et maintenant c'est le coup difficile
il faut le trouver je sais pas lequel
est il fait Damas 5 c'est un joli coup
ça interdit les BK ça contrôle la Colona
mes tours bien il y a pas de il y a pas
de de place pour rentrer dans la
position adverse dame B4 c'est bien il
vient il vient vraiment se placer ce
dans les trous noirs
c'est bien il peut pas trop bouger le
cavalier il y a le cavalier C3 derrière
en ligne de mire avec le fou il revient
à 5 ça c'est un quoi à côté sur B4 il y
a cavalier prend
il a dû prendre peur de quelque chose
mais la dame des cas dame à 5 c'est pas
c'est pas optimal rois H2 F5 c'est le
coup que l'ordinateur voulait depuis
tout à l'heure mais il joue en perdant 2
3 tempo est-ce que ça va être grave on
n'en sait rien
ah c'est dur de on arrive pas à rentrer
là c'est fou toutes les pièces noires
sont tellement bien placées mais on
n'arrive pas à mettre le coup
décisif il va peut-être échanger
remettre un cavalier en B4 avec les
Noirs plus que 6 secondes à lire esa qui
est en train de de prendre un peu trop
son temps il va falloir qu'il nous mette
une grosse accélération maintenant c'est
peut-être l'autre cavalier qui jaillit
en Détroit non tour à trois bien joué
cavalier D1 il y a cavalier 4 ça
commence à chauffer là pour Wesley plus
de 4 secondes 6 secondes et 5 prise prix
c'est prémouv allez allez au bout du
bout des cinq qui fait mal cavalier C2
allez touche-le oh il le touche de
partout il le touche de partout il va
pas réussir à jouer Wesley ça c'est une
tour ou pas tu auras deux il rentre sur
la deuxième
faut prendre des cas tu fais cavaliers
des deux aux cavaliers des deux c'est
joli faut prendre des seins croisés 7 et
il tombe c'est égalité parfaite il reste
plus qu'une minute 10 il reste plus
qu'une minute 10 mesdames et messieurs
et c'est et c'est très partout et ce qui
retourne sur l'italienne il y a pas trop
réussi il réfléchit à lire ça qui
réfléchisse c'était pas un choix facile
parce que ces Italiens elles ont pas
très bientôt tourné là il va pas mettre
le fond j'ai 5 à l'IRESA mais le fond en
E3 mais oui mais oui ne me mets pas ce
fonger 5 et Wesley qui est obligé de
roquer il pouvait plus attendre pour
jouer ça séquence de quoi recoper ça
joue au jeu du chat et de la souris dans
ce dernier Bullet décisif
il a le plan de dubaf là quand même
attention aux plantes de Booba filer
dangereux celui-là dame 8 damage 5 tours
F7 tours F8 en belette il part très très
vite on dirait ça qui va pas se laisser
faire allez on vient en D2 avec le
cavalier on va gère sur la casse C4 là
il va faire dames 8 un plan de douboff
non il fait des cinq
qui tient la casse B3 ouais c'est
stressant puis on prend des cinq je sais
pas pourquoi ça marche pas mais ça
marche pas
il fait des 4 puis on prend la structure
là qui est en train d'arriver est-ce que
ça va partir en E5 structures françaises
est-ce qu'il va juger un petit coup de
H3 mais ça peut être affaiblissant 10
secondes d'avance allez à l'IRESA il a
un tout petit peu devant là dans cette
partie Wesley qui commence à tanquer oh
il tombe pour rien Wesley il tente pour
rien là il vient de tank 20 secondes
gratos et il fait un à trois oui bon bah
ça ça s'appelle un punto prends-le mange
le pion ouais c'est nickel ça 20
secondes pour donner un pion en un c'est
ça qu'on veut voir il va aller le
récupérer peut-être mais attention il a
aussi sous pression il veut quoi il veut
oh il veut sacrifier il veut sacrifiant
F3 oh il veut donner la cale oh il va
faire tout apprendre F3 il le fait pas
autant F3 et ca va aller prendre des
quatre ça avait l'air tellement fort
mais non il le fait pas les tours 3 on
doit on doit serrer la vis il va prendre
à deux maintenant c'est bien joué prises
à deux est-ce qu'on a du dessin tour D8
28 secondes chacun ça va se jouer dans
un mouchoir de poche et la nul oh le
poterie tue des deux joueurs qui veulent
aller en départage en 1+1 oh qu'est-ce
que c'est pleutre de part et d'autre oh
c'est extrêmement pleutre
qui court qui court il va faire la
vidange
qu'est-ce que c'est pleutre des deux
côtés
et donc maintenant vous avez vu en
dessous les règles de départage ça va
être quatre parties en plus
ah mais ouais il est en train de
il devait il devait faire la vidange
liquide
oh c'est sûr oh il y avait des problèmes
de vidange côté
Wesley fallait remplacer lui on l'a vu
il a tout de suite revu derrière
mais très très pleut très des deux côtés
très très très pleutre des deux côtés
aucun des deux hommes n'a voulu prendre
la responsabilité du jeu
et ils font une nulle
pleutre il y a pas d'autres mots
toujours égalitaire donc on a vu un 7-2
un de 7 7 2 4 et demi quatre et demi et
maintenant quatre parties de 1 + 1 on
est dans le tie-break allez allez il va
falloir jouer les bonnes ouvertures et
là il y a Dieu quoi trop on retourne sur
la Sicilienne le fou B5 cavalier 7 à 4
allez cavaliers C3 à 6 son chasse le fou
B6 prise d'un membre des quatre fou B7
on tape sur le pion E4 on a une
structure de type
hérisson
ça qui s'y frotte s'y pique j'ai envie
de dire petit pic de Hérisson et ça
c'est une ouverture qu'on a déjà eu dans
le match je crois qu'il avait remis le
cavagnon à FC si on joue exactement la
même chose
ça montre pas trop les prépas jusqu'au
bout mais ça ça a une cohérence dans le
jeu là j'aime pas ça regardez les cases
blanches elle crie famine une famille
une famille vous avez entendu les pièces
blanches les casses blanches et garde la
dame en D8 ouais ça c'est il a déjà eu
quelque chose de semblable et c'est pas
exceptionnel mais allez il va falloir
développer les pièces
Damas 2
ce qui peut tenter un B5 non il va faire
H5 H4 g4n en là la partie spasmal
qui touche le pion F7 il va falloir
blinder
à donne tellement pas envie on peut se
faire toucher par le cavalier
allez on souffle un bon coup on met les
barbares
vous prend baisser cette dame prend B7
on touche le fou fou fou fou fou F2
cavaliers F4
cavalier C4 il touche encore le pion
assez dur hein on se fait toucher à
gauche on se fait tout ça à droite
dame c'est 6 il va faire cavalier 3 il
va nous toucher F5 ah vous voyez ces
cases blanches on n'arrive pas à s'en
débarrasser de ce problème
allez faut tenter un G4 il faut tenter
quelque chose j'ai cinq H4 et il faut h6
il fait fouger 7 oh là là là c'est une
catastrophe industrielle cette partie
complètement dominée par par Wesley
il veut laisser le pion des 6 pour
essayer de se trouver du jeu on voit le
fond en G7 qui est horrible il est
complètement passé à côté ouais c'est
qui a joué la bonne ouverture mais il a
été plus au train à lireza il a proposé
nul là dans dans la partie précédente
méritait quelque part un d'être puni
pour pour cette décision extrêmement
pleutre
et là la partie elle est
catastrophique
je jouais des coups et difficiles en
regarder on ne sort pas de la cage en
fait
alors il réussit à faire un peu quelque
chose mais
on peut pas on peut pas jouer en fait
allez c'est 5 non il passe derrière il
tient les
tiens tant bien que mal
bah écoute en cours à gauche un coup à
droite mais à vrai dire
allez tours géant tourner en retour
est-ce que Wesley va être assez long il
est pas assez peu pour faire nuit ici
quand même
qui va revenir en F5 il va devoir
remettre le fou a il peut pas aller il
faut jouer
jouer un coup quand même il a réussi
en B1
alors le foot il peut plus jouer il est
complètement enfermé
c'est terrible
allez remettre peut-être une tour en B2
je jouais
jouer des coups
il tente tout ce qui peut mais il y
arrivera pas
avant non dernier Reza attention plus
que trois parties allez faut gagner avec
les Blancs on retourne dans ce
titalienne c'est pas trop mal placé là
quand on a attendu pour le fouger 5 mais
non il retourne au charbon
il retourne dans le rock opposé alors
c'est pas ce qu'il est mené au score
maintenant
c'est parce qu'il est mené au score il
se dit Wesley va pas forcément vouloir
retourner dans le grand rock
on va voir si Wesley elle fait mentir ou
pas
ah il est déterminé ouais c'est aussi
allez peut-être en Dame des 4 allez vite
vite vite vite vite vite sur le roi
adverse
52 secondes contre 58
il fait fou B5 c'est assez logique
ça libère les cases peut-être cavalier
C4 maintenant enchaîner tout de suite
pour taper sur A5
allez c'est bien allez bon début de
partie
ça permet de faire tant que
notre vieille amie so
ion
pas du tout envie et là il tente pour
rien Wesley allez c'est parfait
il tente pour rien dans le sens où toute
façon il peut pas défendre son pion
allez faut aller le manger ça s'appelle
un pion
il faut aller lui taquiner la truffe
un petit coup de dame B3 quand même
peut-être menacer ma tendre un coup mais
il y aura B6 vous pouvez si ce 4 à long
gagne encore un temps Damas 3 on gagne
du temps il faut prendre 5
et on gagne du tiempo et bim
ça c'est un pion et ça donne la case des
4 ouais il fait du bien celui-là ça va
permettre d'enfermer le four
alors il menace même pas dame prend ses
tenu donc on peut faire cavaler des
quatre ou fous prends et fils au foot et
4 mais oui c'est joli ça c'est 5
maintenant faut prendre F6 et cavalier
des deux le fouet bloqué allez il faut
faire le boulot maintenant je vois bien
mettre la tour en vin le pion E5
cavalier 3 allez il faut serrer les
dents là j'ai pas aimé cavaliers 3 j'ai
pas du tout aimé cavalier 3 cavaliers C4
là
H3 il a quand même G3 attention là j'ai
l'impression F4 c'est bien joué
j'ai trois H3 ouais là au moins il ferme
ça c'est très très bien joué F4 ça ferme
complètement et la tour qui va revenir
en F1
et bien joué dame bet3 aussi il se
replace pour pour les maths
et cavaliers à 5 merci Monsieur
cavalier prend ses 6 ça c'est chèque au
roi et d'un macaque ça menace main pas
le temps de mater en G2 côté
ouais c'est les tours F7 et c'est ciao
allez c'est égalise
allez let's go les qualités parfaite
continue 4c6 une petite carreau canne
qui a pas trop mal marché là dans ce
match
sicilienne on a souffert la partie
d'avant il était retourné dans la
Bellevarde oh il joue le cas ici ce qui
va aller au 5
bien joué de la part de Wesley il tente
de surprendre à lire et à feu système
pot il sait pas fait surprendre
justement il faut qu'il vient en D7
solide
solide à l'IRESA il s'est débarrassé de
ce mauvais fou
cavalier F6 on va aller Rocket là c'est
une position complètement correcte on va
pouvoir envoyer l'attaque de minorité oh
il ne pense pas à dédain gris ne pense
pas à des dinguerie oh il est dans du il
est dans une dinguerie il va faire H5
non il pouvait autant tâche 5 H4 pour
foutranger 3 et la draw et tout jouer
sur une partie
va pas falloir être l'autre côté Ali
resa
allez B5 B4 on voyait le jeu ah il veut
tout droit à 8 5 peut-être
allez cavaliers F5 allez ça on prend là
il y a du F4 qui arrive oh j'aime bien
là ce qui s'est passé
bon ça ça va pas être ça va pas être
touché hein ce cavalier H6 qui prend 4
on va on va se laisser
doubler les pions et maintenant il va
faire cavalier 7 cavaliers 5
c'est jouer il va revenir vers la case
FCO
prend F3 fou prend F3 et il faut prendre
j'ai trop et puis on prend j'ai trois
dames quand j'ai trois fougères il y a
rien c'est pas de bol
c'est tellement pas loin de passer cette
histoire
mais à ce moment du match
c'est dur d'aller risquer un truc pareil
et ça tient du coup pour Wesley cavalier
3 il veut quoi
ça m'a échappé mais il devait y avoir un
truc arriver fou prends j'ai trois
pardon donc on se réorganise côté Ali
resa 28 secondes chacun
mais attention ce fou G2 est très fort
il tape sur des 5
et maintenant il tape sur le diagonale
on n'a pas réussi à
faire passer quoi que ce soit et pour ça
que le cavalier va revenir vers le 4
c'est bien joué ça
mais il échange les pièces les unes
après les autres Wesley et ça c'est bien
joué parce que si on se retrouve en
finale un jour le la paire de fou
règnera en maître et là ouais c'est il a
bien il a très très bien défendu tiens
les cases allez dame F5
il va falloir aller me chercher la dro
côté d'ailleurs il en veut pas un de nul
bien entendu Wesley
il va falloir me jouer peut-être un H5
G5 allez c'est bien il veut G4 gagne une
pièce
trop bien joué encore
ça joue fort un des deux côtés personne
veut lâcher le moindre centimètre de
terrain
6 dames j'ai 6 h 5 potes j'aime ça coupe
un peu le jeu
ce qui va réussir à décaler son roi où
il le souhaite est-ce que le roi est
réellement mieux placé en 17 j'en sais
rien mais là sur les derniers coups
c'est plutôt à l'IRISA qui met la
pression mais le fou G4 a fait mal quand
même
on sait pas trop comment progresser il
va peut-être y avoir une proposition de
nul là quelque part
ouais ça va répéter
mais attendez il est peut-être bien oh
ça peut faire la course court il va
courir jusqu'à 4 mais roi de roi B5
roi des 1 roi k3c2 au tempo près
il se fait fermer alors est-ce qu'il
peut mettre le fond F4 oui mais ça va
pas plus loin que ça
ah ça doit être nul ça
et c'est nul au tempo il a réussi à
revenir Wesley et on est de nouveau dans
la même situation que tout à l'heure
tout va se jouer sur cette partie et
maintenant c'est Wesley qui est dans le
doute sur sa variante kg 6 fougait 5
la peur à se changer de camp dans cette
ligne dans la partie précédente c'est
plus la même qui a 10 minutes de ça
maintenant elle ireza accepte de te
prendre le G5 parce qu'il vient de de
lui mettre un caramel et ses Wesley qui
part sur petit Rogue du coup à cause du
caramel qui s'est pris à 10 minutes oh
ça se joue à rien ça se joue dans la
tête on croirait une mêlée là et ouais
c'est comme les meilleurs rugby chaque
partie a sa vérité là on a changé de
stratégie côté Wesley on va voir si
c'est payant ou pas
car le fou qui revient en G6 pour
défendre
je sais pas quoi dire est-ce qu'il va
réussir à organiser du DK il fait à 3
pour B4 c'est pas idiot
46 secondes il va pas falloir être
pleutre là il va falloir aller me la
chercher attention un cavalier qui veut
revenir oh il veut du G4 mais ça pourra
peut-être sacrifier il envoie lui-même
G4
Wesley si le cavalier bouger a prises le
fou qui va devoir revenir en G3
peut-être cavalier G6 là c'est plutôt
Wesley qui a l'initiative du jeu mais il
y a du D4 qui part F5
c'est chaud c'est chaud mais c'est
Wesley la qui a réussi son début puis on
prend le 5 puis on prend le 4 cavaliers
prend ouais je sais pas si quelqu'un a
plus réussi le début que l'autre en
réalité
prend quatre il veut faire quoi il veut
des 5 cavaliers 6 oh c'est bien vu sur
pion premier cavaliers H5 sur cavalier
prend puis on prend puis on prend il y a
pion prend le 7 il y en a absolument de
partout 32 secondes chacun l'égalité est
parfaite dans ce match égalité à la
position égalité au temps égalité au
score après 4h05 de jeu
ça va prendre F6 ça fait cavalier F5 tu
apprends des 5 ça va rentrer dans une
finale attention la colonne H1 qui
pourrait être sensible mais j'ai
l'impression que les Noirs réussissent
pas ramener une tour le fou qui va se
décaler en E4 je suppose j'en sais rien
peut-être il va repartir vers à deux non
il va en E4 il provoque les choses le
cavalier qui va venir peut-être en D4
fermé il vient en H4 ça peut échanger
des tourelles qui est mieux qu'est-ce
qui se passe il y a un pion de plus pour
les blancs mais il y a la paire de fou
pour les noirs de ce cavalier H4 qui est
complètement bloqué pour le moment mais
qui pourra peut-être jaillir un jour en
F5 la septième col rangée pour pour les
blancs autour des 8 tours à huit donne
rien ça donne envie rouage d'un petit
coup autour des 8 quand même
tour et fuite ça va échanger ramener le
cavalier non il fait tourner 600 coups
responsable tout réussis il revient fou
E4 peut-être il va revenir en D8
oh c'est stressant c'est stressant il
veut garder les tours il veut ramener le
cavagnon F3 le l'échange de tour qui
imposé maintenant par Wesley sceaux et
cette finale qui est peut-être
dangereuse oh et ça joue pour la nulle
côté Wesley c'est l'autre
c'est extrêmement pleutre
dès qu'il a pu échanger il a tout
échangé
et maintenant ça va être en Armageddon
oh c'est dommage d'avoir Armageddon
oh bah moi j'aurais continué en bo2
jusqu'au bout en plus là
armage ouais non dommage armaguet donc
j'aurais continué comme ça 1 + 1 bo2
cadence je sais pas quelle est la
cadence
j'ai jamais vu l'Armageddon dans ce truc
là j'ai déjà vu le départage un plus
simple et l'Armageddon je suis jamais
arrivé
un match de quatre parties en plus
enchères avec 5 minutes comme temps de
base
ouais l'Armageddon en chair
ouais c'est dommage de pas envoyer de
continuer en plus un quand même
ouais c'est bizarre un magasin après
belette c'est très très étrange
mais je pense que bo2 en plus un c'était
beaucoup plus drôle que l'Armageddon en
fait
c'est un peu dommage
on aurait voulu
que ça continue jusqu'au bout de la nuit
avec les démons de minuit
ouais mais bon en bo2 bo2 belette je
t'assure que
le match va se finir enfin genre ça va
pas durer 10 plomb
j'ai un moment donné ça
quand ça finit forcément comme ça
un peu décousu
on va voir
je vais essayer de regarder
dans combien de temps ça commence
bon allez
je vais essayer de prendre des infos sur
mon téléphone
je vais essayer de choper des infos sur
je suis en train de faire n'importe
mes lunettes mon téléphone s'allume pas
en plus
c'est trop
ce qu'on trouve une info
non je crois qu'on va pas pouvoir suivre
les enchères de notre côté
on s'en sert reprendre dans une minute
dans une minute ça c'est déjà une info
on a une info
déjà pas mal
ça va reprendre maintenant et après on
verra on verra le tienne pour un qu'ils
ont
on verra le tiempo
c'est stressant ces bolettes
tu dis combien de temps tu veux pour
avoir les Noirs quoi en gros
les Blancs ont 5 minutes les Noirs ont
besoin de faire nuls ils vont enchérir
pour savoir combien ils volent de temps
après à vrai dire
moi je suis en chairai pas si bas si
j'étais alliéza
parce que l'italienne ce qui joue Wesley
c'est très agressif quoi
donc s'il a une ou une trente d'avance
ça peut vraiment que
après c'est mon point de vue
ça vaut ce que ça vaut
genre j'avais pas en dessous de 4
minutes côté côté
armage je trouve que c'est un peu
bizarre moi je trouve sur ces matchs là
qui sont très très longs de toute façon
le match genre c'est 4h de Blitz donc
c'est déjà des matchs à rallonge
je trouve que c'est dommage de pas finir
sur des bo2 enfin genre tu fais bo2 bo2
bo2 bo2 bo2 en 1+1 au final
bah ok ils vont faire un nul de 3000
4000 5000 et puis 20 au bout d'un moment
ça va pas durer une heure allez ça part
on va voir les temps il est en chérie à
3 39 à lire et ça
ouais alors attention il y a pas de
rajoint armaguette il y a pas de rajout
donc c'est 3 39 sec
c'est de mon point de vue un choix très
courageux de la part du joueur français
j'aurais pas descendu en dessous de 4
personnellement mais écoutez on espère
que le choix s'avère payant en tout cas
il a il a confiance dans son dans son
italienne avec les noirs
on va essayer de lui faire autant
confiance qu'à Zizou dans les arrêts de
jeu
quoi c'est qui va devoir jouer pour le
gain mais d'un côté contre nature et
d'un autre côté on sait quoi c'est quand
il est obligé de jouer le gain il sait
le faire aussi
mais là vous voyez comme il y a pas le
plus une seconde
il faut il faut être très méfiant
n'oubliez pas tout à l'heure même dans
le bolet c'était du 1 + 1
les parties athénées régulièrement les
90 coups donc au final ça fait deux
minutes 30 donc ça va très très vite
ouverture réussie de part et d'autre je
pense que Wesley est très content
de la position qu'il a mais mais à les
raisins aussi
tiens la case G5 C3
cavalier G4 il veut forcer il veut
forcer la décision en B6
reprendre de a pour le moment il tient
bien
position à St égale des 4 il prend le
centre
tour qui vient 8 attention le pion F7
qui peut être sensible
il faudra garder ça
dans un coin de la tête le cahier qui
revient et c'est bien là les raisins
vient de jouer une bonne série de coups
il a joué vite bien plus qu'une minute
de retard il est revenu un petit peu au
temps et surtout il a réussi à arrêter
l'hémorragie temporelle
donc la plus de 3,50 il a blindé le
centre on n'a pas de fou aussi
malheureusement et on peut faire fouger
4 et sur H3 repartir par là il va faire
foudre à tempo allez c'est bien il
réussit à jouer des coups vite et facile
alors est-ce qu'il a des cinq
ouais trop risqué il va faire dams 8
cavalier 7
ok
tu prends 5ds 5 cavaliers prend ah il
veut [__] en B5 après en B5 tu
reprends un dame prend un dame prend des
deux désolé messieurs j'avais pas
variante facile mais après 4 heures de
jeu il faut encore les voir et donc là
ca va aller prendre des 7 c'est ultra
solide
qui joue une partie quasiment parfaite
ici
cavalier 6 cavaliers F3 cavaliers 6 il
tient
de 38 ça y est il est revenu au temps
quasiment
il va mettre la dame en 17 il va
peut-être aller naviguer jusqu'en C6
allez ne pas prendre trop de temps
il veut quoi il veut quoi ouais c'est là
il me fait peur avec son C4
il me fait peur avec son C4 je sais pas
où il veut en venir mais ils vont venir
quelque part ah ça c'est un punto allez
prends-le
ça c'est
ça c'est Punto
OK
oh
ça c'est Punto quand même
allez tour à 6 bien joué
puis on prend le 5 il a qu'à prendre le
5 et prend le 5 tours 5 évidemment
et là c'est punto de plus position
solide ne pas se mettre en galère autant
cavalier des cas tu veux venir vers la
case F5 allez continue à jouer solide
cavalier F6 toujours 7 minutes de retard
attention à la Une 57 sans le plus
simple
ça peut faire mal
pour y avoir peut-être un jour des dames
proches je crois qu'elle va aller F3
cavalier prend des deux à garder en
garder en mémoire il revient en G6
ça stresse là ça stresse de partout
attention de pas se prendre un cavalier
cavalier 7 cavalier F5 dans 6 nage
médina
tu auras 5 c'est pour que justement
l'idée
et sur B4 attention un sur B4 tour E5
il veut tenter un truc comme ça c'est
sûr qu'il a ça en tête Wesley il fait F4
ça va ça nous soulage un petit peu
mais pas complètement quand même ça peut
arriver avec du Dam D4 cavalier prend H6
aussi j'aime pas cette minute de retard
là qui persiste une 28 contre 28 comme
je vous ai dit il y a pas de rajout de
temps il y a pas de rajout de temps
attention attention on s'approche
dangereusement là dès une minute
on s'en rapproche très très
dangereusement Wesley là qui vient de
faire une grosse série et là alors Didi
cavalier prend G7 roi prangée 7 B4 oh là
l'idée mortelle est en train d'arriver
là
dame c'est 6 c'est bien joué mais s'il
trouve pas cavalier G7 surtout je pense
pas que ce soit trouvable après c'est la
bonne nouvelle
parce que sur B4 il veut peut-être tout
reprendre
il a commencé par Roche 2
cavalier prend le 4 ça semble giga
risqué
il y a des coups comme d'hab B2 qui font
très très très très très très très très
peur
mais plus qu'une 03 a toujours 7 minutes
de retard il y a plus le plus une
seconde à lire et ça j'ai envie de lui
crier
il le joue oh là là là là là là là
F6 cavalier ranger 7 oh j'ai peur
même des quatre cavaliers F6 il y a
cavalier H6 ou cavalier G7 ici
il faut qu'il joue à l'IRESA il faut
qu'il joue
tu reprends cavalier prend il va
remettre la tour en 8 et faire cavalier
prend H6 après sur dame prend 8 qui est
rangé 7 roi prangée 7 BK toujours pour
l'ordi mais ça va pas être trouvé ça
ah si trouve il fait mal hein s'il
trouve cavaler chez sa 3g7b il le trouve
il le trouve et après il y a cavalier H5
et plus de 40 secondes à lire et ça qui
a pas cette seconde de rajout je le
rappelle
ah ça fait trop mal plus de 36 secondes
il a été trop gourmand à lireza avec les
trois 39 trop gourmand
alors c'est pas fini encore mes 33
secondes ça va être trop juste à mon
avis il va nous falloir un exploit il
hésite entre cavaliers H5 et cavalier 5
mais ouais là il rentre à l'IRISA qui
est tellement mal à qui va probablement
s'incliner roi G8 dans F6 dans mes F8
tours 8 cavaliers h6a ou cavalage 6,8
plutôt il a oublié qu'il y avait pas la
seconde de rajout il a oublié qu'il y
avait pas la seconde de rajout
c'est sûr sinon il jouerait plus vite il
a juste oublié il y a une seconde de
rajout depuis 4 heures
il a oublié qu'il allait plus
et à Wesley aussi parce que sinon c'est
Dame prend des 8 et c'est terminé
alors réalire eza qui tente sa dernière
chance mais il a plus de temps et il va
s'incliner très mauvais choix
stratégique de mon point de vue 39 pas
assez avec les noirs
mais on le voit il lui manquait du temps
aussi de la position à l'IRESA qui
s'incline
et oui il s'incline le match compensé
plié après 40 minutes de jeu avec une
victoire d'Ali resa de Wesley facile
finalement ça c'est pas terminé comme ça
ça s'est terminé après 4h30 de jeu mais
c'était quand même victoire de Wesley
pour moi ouais très beau match
évidemment mais mais
erreur de choix
erreur erreur
erreur dans le choix et dans le temps
dans le temps pris et ouais c'est ceux
qui réussissent à l'emporter
mais ouais on aurait quand même préféré
un bo2 et on voit que le changement de
cadence ça fait mal à lirea pas réussi à
se mettre dans le rythme et surtout il a
réellement oublié qui avait pas le plus
simple c'est peut-être ça qu'il a poussé
à faire ce choix un petit peu étrange
mais dommage dommage que ça se finisse
là dessus après il faut féliciter Wesley
qui
n'était plus forcément favoris
quand on est arrivé à la section belette
qui a réussi à résister et qui l'emporte
à l'armée et donc
c'est comme ça
il faut l'accepter
mais ouais il a payé quelques petits
paye des décisions à lireza mais
vraiment sur le tempo là après il aurait
gagné on aurait crié au génie
mais une 22 de différence
c'était quand même beaucoup
surtout qu'il semblait être pas mal avec
les Blancs et qui s'envait pas avoir
besoin de forcer les noirs
bon du coup moi je vais vous faire un
petit
je vais essayer de faire une petite
série de parties pédagogique
avant de avant de rentrer donc je vais
aller sur ma chaîne je peux pas mettre
de raid parce que j'ai pas le j'ai pas
l'accès pour le faire donc si vous
souhaitez une petite voir une petite
série de parties pédagogiques je vais
tenter de les faire je sais pas si si je
vais si je vais y arriver parce que
5 heures de live c'est beaucoup mais je
vais tenter
et on se quittera après cela merci à
tous d'avoir suivi ce speechess et on se
retrouve très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures ici qui aiment à bientôt les
amis enfin à tout de suite pour ceux qui
me suivent et sinon